comments. Okay, we disagree on that because I view a transformative
work as definitionally not being a market replacement. If it
is a market replacement, it is not transformative. It is strong.
Literally the four pillars of fair use based like I understand
that but you're saying like I you're just saying you don't live
in reality that he thinks might be immoral but not necessarily
something he should go after legally. You think
by going after denims. You can't go after children. No, he isn't.
That's not true. You don't know that. that needs to be adjudicated,
right? No, I'm just saying no, I would just say that this is
how I personally view it. What do you mean I don't live in reality?
I we can have separate definitions. Maybe even my definition
dude Solvin's position on this. Look how sad I am. All right,
cool. Wow. Wow.
Wow. Oh, don't go there. Wait, hold on. What is this? Nah. Nah.
Nah. Damn. Okay, I think I'm gonna fire up Pisco versus Hutch
on the Ethan Klein stuff and then probably just about done here.
We'll see Pisco versus Hutch real quick. Pisco
versus Hutch on H3 lawsuits.
Let's check this out. I think that if the courts start to heavily
limit class action, then yes, you're going to see more litigation.
But, you know, time will tell how court are going to respond
to this. Um, but it will encourage every individual plaintiff
to get out their own lawyer and to file their lawsuit that they
send that they're like about to be harmed by like a blatant unconstitutional
thing. So this this could potentially have an enormous impact
on legal practice itself, right? Like because because we might
theoretically see like Okay, Queenman, are you here right now?
I'm guessing we we flip from the Supreme Court decision to the
Ethan Klein stuff after this like a lot more
we don't really care about the broader implications of like your
contract dispute this or that, right? And we we don't expect
an order that extends beyond the parties and so it's really just
the government but the people who sued to say the terrors are
unconstitutional and now you can't afford to go off is like Trump's
lawyers saying that. How could this have impacted Biden's administration
for example with the legal issue? um it just seems wrong on its
face in my opinion um based on what the principles of equity
are but the court is hyperfixated on their version of historical
analysis and they would okay so Trump has already tried maybe
a number of times to basically end I think that that's not super
likely but that's maybe how we manifest like somehow the requirement
to vote um was up whether this is illegal everyone seems really
addressed that but it's just funny but I said this entire time
I think is a strong case so yeah disagree but like I think it
can be both like he can they're fighting or something or like
the when there's a couple fighting in the in the restaurant and
something or like the other couple or something but no I'm I'm
down to fight what do we what do you think we disagree Um, let
me here we go. On the Ethan, what do you think about Ethan? Is
that is that what you were going to fight on? Because you're
a big Ethan.
I'm trying to understand what your position was because you were
regarding like the Ethan lawsuit. You were I think Tell me if
I'm wrong, but I think your position was that he has standing.
I don't know if I'm using that word right. I'm not a legal person,
but uh I think what you're saying is that he has standing, but
you didn't he has a good case, but you didn't like the way he
was positioning himself publicly. you you I think your issue
was that he was framing it as like I'm doing this for the greater
good of like the YouTube ecosystem and all that when really it
was just about like a petty um like a petty grudge that he has.
Uh yeah, essentially kind of. Yeah, the fact that he would hang
on. Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I just have a donation without the means
to litigate being Do you think the ruling will lead to some national
citizens without the means to litigate being deported? Um I think
we'll ultimately get a class action and that will be prevented.
So my if I had to guess the answer would be no to that. I don't
think that will happen. Um but we'll see. We'll see. Um you basically
got it. I take issue with him presenting himself as defending
the reaction community and I think that that's a completely rationale
and I think that the complaint is unhinged. Those were my two
points and people have completely lost it and started attacking
me and uh and I think that that's just it's on one sense funny.
Uh but I've said this entire time I think he has a strong case.
So yeah, that's my position. how much we disagree, but like I
think it can be both. like he can I think what happened with
him is like he he got you know this whole thing really escalated
to a new level like once CPS was called and so uh like if you
put yourself in his shoes and just imagine what that
how much disagree but like I think it can be both like he can
I think what happened with him is like he he you know this whole
thing really escalated to a new level like once CPS was called
and so like if you put yourself in his shoes and just imagine
what that experience was like to have Again,
again, people with no understanding of time government show up
at your house and you know, basically uh compel him and Hila
to demonstrate to the state that they're capable of raising their
own child. Like I'm sure that probably
I think like Pisco's got a good idea of what the timeline is.
This is like the core thing of everybody who like tries to argue
with me on this. I'd say this is the most common thing. People
are like, "What is he not supposed to he is he supposed to like
not want to sue these people after the CPS calls? What do they
call CPS? They're skull sent." It's like, okay, bro, he clearly
said he wanted to sue them before uh before he registered it.
He registered it before he released it explicitly because he
wanted to sue them. That's all before CPS. It's not even not
even an argument. Um kicked him into a new kind of gear. And
I was telling my chat like I think it would be it'd be one story
if the CPS got called on his house and then like all the creators
in the Hassan cinematic universe kind of all said to their own
communities like, "Okay, this is going too far. We need to take
the temperature down a I think Denims did say afterwards that
like, "Hey, uh, you shouldn't do this. Like, focus on some real
world engagement. This is stupid. Don't do this." Uh, so she
did and Assan just straight up from the very beginning said,
"That's unhinged. Don't do that. That's crazy."
So, I don't I don't even know like reality doesn't matter at
all apparently. Um, that that would have been one thing, but
that's not what we saw happen. What we saw happen was, you know,
number one, they denied that it came from their communities,
which was kind of crazy to me. Number two, you know, why would
that be crazy to you? Can we get any evidence that this came
from Denim's community or Hassan's community or like you can't
you can't just have communities that are looser related and a
bad action happens that might be from one of them and you get
to blame all of them. That can't be how that works. That's insane.
We all agreed on this when the capital happened that it's insane
to do that. That is literally there's just Oh, we forget. We
forget. Apparently they like double tripled quadrupled down.
So like instead of saying obviously it's way too far to call
CPS. We saw a lot of these same creators that were like well
I don't know. I mean he was talking about like dog poop and you
know like I I he was you can say that and also say
you can say well uh you shouldn't do that. It's a waste of time.
It's it's bad. Don't do that. But also I don't know why this
talking about dog [__] and his kids eating dog and
stuff or whatever the [__] his kids crawling around
in a house with dog [__] in it. I don't know. That's
stupid. I do think people have a right to be concerned about
his kids and blah blah blah blah blah. And I think like once
they did that, he probably resolved in that moment to like really
with them. Yeah. Um but I I agree with that, but and listen,
I don't know. I think that some of them condemned it or said
that they wouldn't do it. Maybe you're right that some of them
kind of played cutesy about it or whatever. Um which is, you
know, I don't agree with that. I don't agree with them calling
it. And um and that's all cool. And but you said something at
the start which I find to be the relevant part. Like I don't
dispute that that's probably why he sued had to do something
with that or their previous grievances. That's my whole point.
But you said it could be both. Yeah, it could be both, but it's
not. I'm saying it's not. It's not both. It's one and it's not
the other. Yeah, it's clearly one and not the other. It could.
They're not necessarily mutually exclusive, but I'm saying it's
not one. That's my point. I'm not saying that you don't think
you you don't think that, for example, like you don't think that
it's plausible for him to have seen their
um like what like surely you agree that the that the that the
lengths that they went or the the the
way that they went about reacting to his video was super malicious,
right? Like I feel like we probably both agree on that. malicious.
You mean they had a stated intention to steal money from him?
Then the answer is yes. Yeah. The stated explicit like they weren't
even like koi about it. They weren't even subtle. They didn't
try to use like code language. They just came out and said like,
"Hey, watch it here so you don't give Oh, another person hutch."
Another person who doesn't understand the strict liability crime.
I agree that they said that and that would put their that would
be a justifiable reason to go after them and not other people.
I on that I'm not disagreeing at all. That's not what I'm but
my point is he's not trying to defend the React community. That's
my point. And he he holds himself out as doing that. And you
don't reject that, do you? He is holding himself as defending
broadly the React community. Well, I think he's like my position
is like it's it's plausible that he's doing both. So, here's
the thing. Okay, I want to explain to you guys why people think
Pisco spends a whole bunch of time talking about motivations.
Okay, it should be very obvious to you. What Pisco just did was
he said Hutch is like, "Wait, you you think like it was malicious?"
And he's like, "Oh, if by malicious you mean this, then yes,
I concede that immediately." Right? Pisco just knows the case.
He knows the actual facts and he just says, "Hey, if this is
what you mean, if this is what you mean by malicious, yeah, I
can see that immediately when Pisco is correct on something like
clearly he said he's holding himself up as like some kind of
defender of the rack community." Yes. Hutch goes, "Well, well,
right." He doesn't actually he doesn't just say, "Oh, yeah. Obviously,
that's why Pisco that's why they bog down in like the motivation
stuff and people get really mad at about Pisco's coverage because
when Pisco is correct on something, he will argue it when he
when he knows that he is uh when when the other person is correct
on something, he will concede it immediately. He doesn't have
to argue it. He doesn't care. Like that he felt personally agreed
by these people in their communities like and and like the Snark
subreddit because they were fully psychotic and unhinged as well
with the lengths that they were going to to with Ethan. Um, so
I I think like he was personally agreved by these people in that
way, but also like it's not totally implausible in my mind that
he saw that the the way that they went about reacting to his
content was actually something that was worth um clarifying with
the with the courts. No, it is it is so so it is okay. Yeah.
Yeah. We agree on the one that the personal grievance stuff we
we don't need to talk about more because we agree that that's
at least probably motivating. I think it's plausible that that's
motivating him for sure. So totally agree on that. The only question
is, is he trying to protect the React community? That's the rationale
that I take issue with. And I guess the first question is, do
you think he's trying to give that as a stated rationale that
this is about protecting the React community from an existential
risk? That's Did he say that it was about protecting? See, this
is why like I don't even have to watch more of this debate to
know that Hutch gets totally dumpstered in it cuz I can already
tell if Hutch can't immediately concede the facts that are obvious
like against his argument, then he has no chance. He'll just
get bounced around. He has no idea what he's talking about clearly
react community or did he say it was about protecting protecting
um like YouTubers creations? So this is what okay I he said I'm
going to pull it up uh what he said he said react community commentary
community maybe maybe commentary community right but those are
broadly the same thing those are close to the same thing I guess
Hutch is trying to differentiate between oh the community people
who react to things or just all creative YouTubers like I guess
it would be like authors like creative authors instead of just
people reacting right or what would it be there's a there's a
term but basically like people who are producing unique um new
creative works. Is he trying to protect them? And no, it was
the commentary community that he was trying to protect. Exactly.
But in essence, actually, I'm just going to wait to actually
pull it up. So, H3, I'm suing these creators. H3, I'm suing.
Boom. H3, I am suing these three creators. And then we'll go
directly to the transcript. I'm filibustering. We got the transcript.
I'll go transcript. I'm still filing. I'm talking error. I'm
talking, you know, you could be right. Pisco is learning how
to stream. It's so good. I don't remember the exact verbage.
I don't remember. It's like, but you actually need to do that.
It's so crazy that like you'll have people drop off if you don't
do that. If you don't like fill dead air in some way. But to
me, I thought like that the the emphasis that he made was about
like protecting content creat.
Yeah. I mean, you don't have to if you want to have like um I
don't know you like you'll just have people drop off. They'll
just drop like a two-hour video. Yeah, but something's playing.
That's not dead air. Definitionally not dead air. Uhhuh.
And the video was doing quite well. Just put some backing music
in Queenman. Okay. Some royalty-free backing music and it'll
never be dead air again ever. People won't be able to accuse
you of that. Then credit Kenny for it once they stop accusing
you of that. Okay. And then I think like tons of other creators
like XQC Hassan and a bunch of other people um reuploaded reactions
to that video within like a day or two and there was very minimal
commentary. They basically just like let the video play. I don't
want to speak about Hassan because I'm sure he did. But I know
when it came to XQC he basically was it was just like he was
just kind of staring at the screen every once in a while. Jet
jet. Oh my god. Oh my god. And then I I think also in the case
of XC, I don't want to like slander anybody. I think what his
thumbnail person did was was make the thumbnail very similar
to like Lemino's thumbnail. So I like my sense when when Ethan
was talking about like protecting the ecosystem was more that
he was like trying to protect the creators that make these videos
that people are reacting to and not necessarily like he was posturing
to be the savior of the React community. I could be wrong. This
is the quote. Yeah. to the quote. Oh, Hutch is confused about
Ethan's stance in 2023, which probably was more about unique
creators and not necessarily the commentary community in 2023,
but Pesco is talking about his stated 2025 stance that I keep
going back to is the following. Though theoretically, I could
sue a lot more creators and rake in millions of dollars. Um,
but the purpose of this is not financial gain. People like XQC
and Asmold may have watched the entire thing, but I would never
sue them just for doing that. And I'll go to the next part, but
right there you agree he's acknowledging that XQC and Asminold
are infringing on his work. Right. Also that line there is actually
no way to deny the malice because that line where he says theoretically
I could sue a lot more content creators. But just now he said
about Shauna Black. If I had a case against Shauna Black, I would
have included him in the first place. I would have already filed.
So which one is it? It can't simultaneously be if I had aa good
case I would have filed and I could have sued a lot more but
I didn't. Those can't coexist. that is mutually
I don't think it's mutually exclusive. It could be that Sean's
work is just like giga transformative and like but there are
tons of creators who had no transformity to their stuff at all.
Right. Like if Sean's work that doesn't that doesn't make sense
with the fact with the facts though because we already know Denm
is pretty transformative.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean exactly. It's not it's literally not about
that. Yeah. Um but Yeah. Yeah. Millions of dollars. I would just
say the denim thing already proved to them, right? Um, yeah,
it sounds it's like from the very beginning, this is obviously
just had no I mean, yeah, to anyone with [__] eyes,
but yeah. Yeah, like it. Okay. Uh, then he says, "But I would
never sue them just for doing that. I don't want to chill the
reaction community." That's broadly like the reaction. I don't
want to kill the reaction community in uh into fear. Actually,
the opposite. What's the opposite of chilling the reaction community
to fear? It's defending them, defending their speech, defending
their community, defending all of their their rights and privileges.
Protecting the reaction community, right? It's to make them more
willing and act to do reactions, right? Instead of get into fear
is encouraging the reaction community, right? That's the opposite.
Couldn't Couldn't you argue though? Couldn't you argue that like
his rational could be that he's protecting them by setting uh
like publicly setting a like having a set of standards that that
is his argument. Yes, that is that is what he is arguing. Yes.
And and Pisco isn't saying whether or not he is sincere in that.
Sorry, Pisco isn't actually asking right now whether or not he's
sincere or whether or not he's doing that. He's just saying,
"Do you believe this is his argument?" So Hutch has conceded.
Hutch forgot what the original question was.
That's where he's going to go. And that's where we're going to
go next. He says, "Uh, exactly the opposite. I hope that we can
all unite against this type of egregious behavior that not only
makes us all look bad, but could destroy the commentary community
as we know it." And then he references the potential of Sony
and Disney suing. So he is saying that part of his reasoning,
correct? Is to protect the reaction community broadly, right?
Mhm. Okay. Yeah. There are some So just when we're going back
to when Pisco asked that question, that's the same question Pisco
re asks and and just confirms that is a concession there, right?
If Hutch was going to do well in this conversation, he would
have just said, "Yes, obviously." Right? Right off the bat. He
would have just gone, "Yeah, obviously." and and the lack of
that like found fundamental like first level of knowledge I this
conversation can't people who are contesting whether or not he
ever said that he wanted to protect the broader community and
this is what I take to be the disingenuousness he says XQC and
Asminold should not be chilled he doesn't want to chill XQC and
Asminold even though at the start of his own video he says that
it's an injustice when this happens not just when it's intentional
siphoning but when there when XQC one of the prime suspects basically
watches a whole video and gives no effort or no transformative
anything into it. He calls that quote an injustice. Very famously,
Ethan was having these massive debates with XQC saying, "It's
wrong what you do." I find it so funny, by the way, that even
for this one video, XQC couldn't just do Ethan a solid and not
copy the thumbnail and title almost exactly, right? Like he had
to do the same behavior that Ethan criticized him for precisely
on YouTube. Like literally just copy paste your Pog face on the
title onto the thumbnail. Yeah. And then basically XCC reacts
to content nucle
like it's just it's exactly everything Ethan was actually railing
about in 2023 is very funny. Uh XC it's an injustice what you
do. You ought not do that and it's very everyone knows that right?
So this is the problem. He cannot say or he should not say or
it's inconsistent for him to say I want to not chill. I want
to protect the thing I say is an injustice. That's the inherent
disingenuousness. He's saying that he doesn't want to chill what
he calls an injustice. But of course, why would you not want
to chill what you're calling an injustice? Why would you want
to protect the thing that you say should not be done? That's
what's not doesn't pass a smell test. Well, I think I think I'm
just trying to read between the lines here, but like you could
make the argument that like him going after these particularly
egregious Well, I mean, I'm not a they're not particularly egregious
violators for one thing. Okay. Well, Denims isn't. Sorry. Denims
isn't. Casey Trron almost certainly is lawyers. So, I don't know
if I I'm qualified to call it egregious. I mean, I did see a
bunch of lawyers react to it. It seems to be a consensus among
lawyers. You tell me if I'm wrong. I see a consensus. By the
way, I don't know if this annoys you, Quimman, but when I watch
some of the legal analyses,
they basically just look at Ethan's claims from the video and
evaluate them as if they're true, right? If they evaluate like
the cases, everything Ethan said is true. Yeah. They don't actually
go and watch any of the underlying content. They're just like,
"Well, you know, they didn't react at all. So, obviously Ethan's
gonna just totally win." It's like, "Okay, I
think Legal Mindset went and watched the So, he just did this
like yesterday or today. Ethan Klein versus Orbittors full complaint
review live. Uh, might check this out. Might watch this in the
background at some point. Um,
I'm like doing dishes or something. I don't know. We'll see.
The full legal mindset video wrong that Ethan has a pretty strong
case, but which I could be wrong. I mean, I feel like there were
a lot of like pretty neutral um legal YouTubers that were opining
on this saying that he has a really strong case, but yeah, which
I've never I've nevered. I feel like, you know, if if you're
Ethan, you know, you could look at this as a way to um sort of
steer reactors in a better direction. So like with through his
like loss of litigation with denims and fro the Goldilocks argument.
Listen, we might get the exact precedent that just that doesn't
really chill anything and only includes the things I don't like.
We might get that precisely them. You know, maybe this leads
to people like Asmin Gold and XQC
um starting to adopt like certain standards. No, no, he's saying
I would never sue them. He's saying I would. To be clear, as
much as I hate Asmin Gold, and as much as his commentary is kind
of a lot of the time, he does substantially react to all these
videos. He does add length. He does like he absolutely does.
Okay. Asmin Gold getting included with XQC kind of disingenuous.
XQC is just totally steals content a lot of the time. As Gold
shouts people out, links the video, says go support them, actually
gives commentary. It's like a very, very different approach.
So, give me two seconds. I'm would never sue you as gold. He
He's saying he doesn't want to change. said, "No, he said he
would never sue them uh for the kind of React content that they
were doing, but that was separate from the kind of React content
that Dems and Frogan were doing." No, I I acknowledge that. Well,
different in the sense that one has to say it malicious intent,
the other doesn't. But he's literally saying I I I would never
sue XC and Asold. I would never go after them. Even though he
acknowledges that what they're doing is an injustice. So why
would you at the start of the video he says it's an injustice
and that XC is one of the quote prime suspects and he's on record
saying that what XC does is wrong. And so why would he say something
like, "Oh, I wouldn't want to chill them. I wouldn't want to
change their content." He's he's trying to say, "I don't want
to change what XC and Asmin Gold are doing." Part of his rationale
isn't to to change what XC and Asmin Gold are doing. It's to
preserve and protect what XC and Asmin Gold are doing. That's
what's That's not how I That's not how I interpreted what he
said. I like I was He didn't say he would literally never sue
them. He says literally I would never sue them just for doing
that for for watching my whole video without giving any commentary.
He said I would I would never sue Yeah, but that's in a separate
category that from what denims and probing were doing. I I already
Okay, hold on. Hold on. No, it's not. No, it's not. No, it's
not. No, it's not. No, it's not. The only separate category is
a category that doesn't actually like say whether or not you've
infringed on copyright. It's the malicious intent thing. Like
that's
whatever. So like if X so if like XQC and Asmin Gold did what
Denims and uh Froggen and and the other people did, then he would
them. I agree that that they're not that there's a difference
in what uh they did. I'm not like arguing that there isn't a
difference. Okay, I want to be clear. I'm not arguing that there's
a difference between what XQC does and what um that there's no
difference between what XC does. Sorry. I'm talking about by
the way with respect to fair use. That's that's like uh fair
use sorry and the uh strict liability crime. Obviously, the maliciousness
in terms of if you want to sue somebody, you want to sue somebody
because they said you explicitly, yeah, you can pick whatever
action all you want, right? He literally could have just sued
only the black creators who reacted.
That's his right, right? He could he could have just done that.
Actually,
how does that work? If he were to just pick the black people,
are you allowed to do that? Is that like some equal protections
thing that you couldn't go after? Cuz technically he could just
say, "Well, if any people of color reacted to this, I'm trying
to think of why not. Unless he could prove that he did it because
they're black." Well, what if he stated it? What if he said it
explicitly? I'm just gonna sue the black people who are suing
me or sorry who watch my content.
I don't know
one more time just for not for you for the audience. I am not
saying that there is no difference between what XQC did and what
Frogan at all did. I am not saying that. All I'm saying is one
of the stated intent here by saying I would never sue these people
is oh right the equal protection clause only applies to government
action. Right. So yeah, maybe you could because he doesn't want
to chill these kinds of people. He wants to the opposite. By
the way, if that's actually a good hypothetical for people like
if Ethan had only sued Arab content creators. If that had been
his goal to only sue Arab content creators who react to it, would
that be criticizable? Uh with political climate, I probably think
it would be criticized. uh he might not be criticized by all
these people, but like I think a lot of people would have to
agree that that would be something criticizable and then it's
like, okay, so I can I can criticize him for being a petty [__]
about this. Don't tell me you can't criticize somebody's reason
for for suing. You absolutely can. He wants to protect them.
And what doesn't make sense is the notion that you would want
to protect that which you say shouldn't happen. Why would you
want to? And the best analogy for this is the is the thief analogy.
Um, you would never say, would you, that like, okay, people might
come to my house and steal my money, and there could be people
who do it maliciously, that is to help themselves, but they don't
really care about hurting me. And the people who steal from my
house literally just to hurt me. And I I will, you know, because
it's so much worse to me when someone steals my money specifically
to hurt me, I'm justified in going after those people as opposed
to the non-malicious thieves. But you would never say, and but
let's say that you say it's an injustice when people steal from
me, no matter what. You would never say something like this.
Well, I'm going after the malicious thieves to protect the non-malicious
thieves, which who I say are an injustice. That's what doesn't
make sense. Well, I think he's not saying like he wants to protect
non-malicious thieves. I I think like a good He is saying that
because he said that I would never sue FC. I wouldn't want to
chill. I'm saying I think if we So, like if we assume good faith
for Ethan, like let's just assume for the sake of the argument
that he's being genuine when he says he wants to protect the
React community. I think the only way that that the only conclusion
you could you could come to as far as like his methods for trying
to engineer change basically like like reform within the React
community is that by by having this lawsuit clarify a few things
cuz my understanding is that the React stuff is still like very
much in a gray area legally like there was a there was a decision
when it he sued I think he was sued by someone and and the judge
from what I read basically said that you know his ruling was
not necessarily he wasn't saying that all React content is uh
is fair use and that it would have to be like up to the like
individual cases that that come in the future. He was saying
that specifically Ethan was fair use but he didn't necessarily
define what fair use was. Oh shi so like so so through this process
we could we could get some kind of a decision or some kind of
ruling that could set a precedent that could like give more clarity.
Otherwise the potential like really bad outcome that could happen
is like if you sued someone like xuc or asthmold maybe you get
a precedent that uh that ends up in his like in his words like
chilling the react community. it becomes like way too broad and
then people are just so way too scared of litigation to do any
kind of react content. But by but by specifically focusing on
the malicious actors, you could get a more sort of like precisely
defined
uh interpretation of the
I really hope Pisco push pushes back against this because I'm
pretty confident that this should be the point where he says
no no you can't get that malice thing written into the law. I
think that should happen, but now that I think about it, Queen
didn't know for sure and you watch this content, so maybe that
isn't something they discuss statutes. So, so first off, even
accepting that frame, which I don't accept. Um, because I I deny
the the predicate in the first place, and we'll talk about that.
Even accepting that that's what he's saying, it would entail
being delusion delusional because only a delusional person would
think that they would be able to cabin whatever precedent comes
out of this to be targeted. Oh. to intentional siphoning when
intentional siphoning and intentionality isn't an element of
fair use. Oh,
there it is. Yeah, precisely.
Precisely. Oh, god. Thank you. Yes. Hey, Chris. Thank for Thanks
for the raid, dude. Thank you. Hello, Chris viewers. Hello. Um,
yeah, there it is. Boom. In 4K. The idea that like the precedent
could be set on Malice here is don't talk about it. You're stupid.
Please stop. Please stop. Please stop embarrassing yourself.
Please stop embarrassing everybody who agrees with you. You're
just you're all in like some group humiliation ritual that you
need to exit immediately. Thank you. Thank you. And isn't an
element of copyright infringement? And so it would be bizarre,
wrong, inappropriate
uh to suggest that any kind of precedent that you would have
the expectation that it would be limited to the kind of infringement
that um Ethan says that he wants to get rid of. query. Why wouldn't
we want to get rid of all infringement? Right? So Ethan seems
to say that I want to protect some amount of infringement. Right?
He says that, right? He's saying I want to protect I think he's
No, I think he's saying he wants to protect fair use. Well, no,
he says I could sue more creators and rake in millions of dollars.
So there there are infringers that he could sue, but he doesn't
want to chill them because the because the potential outcome
of again a potential outcome of suing someone like XQC or or
um Asmin Gold. Dude, there's no way. How the could you come on
this stream and just have no no idea whatsoever about like what
XQC's reaction was like and what Denim's reaction was like? Could
end up with a with a with an opinion that's like way more broad.
Wait, and this couldn't um I suppose, but I think there's less
risk in this. So what nobody seems to understand here, what the
the primary point is is because malice is not an element of very
use of copyright infringement because that malice that malice
can basically only be used I guess um possibly in calculating
damages and possibly um like the malicious intent is a an is
superlative. It's it's superlative over um willful intent. So
it is proof of willful intent, right? So it's it's okay for those.
But in terms of proving the actual copyright infringement, proving
um working in terms of fair use, intentionality is not an element.
There will be no precedent written in for intentionality. You
can't do that. That would require some amendment of the law.
Right? So, so you can't do that. It's literally impossible to
do that, right? Because it's impossible to do that. Ethan's intent
can't be that. A lawyer would have told him, "No, no, no. That's
that's not something we can do here." But he's presented that
as if it were the case. Yeah. So, Hutch is just wrong. Why? Why
would you say? No, no. I would say because of because of the
particular egregious nature of their malice. No, but but that's
not an element in the fair use analysis or in the the test for
infringement. You know, intentional siphoning is not an element,
right? I could I could intend to siphon money from you, but give
a fair use work, right? I could say, I really want to steal from
Hutch. I'm going to do this, but it turns out that my work is
fair use, right? It's it's a strict liability offense. Um this
uh the infringement aspect of it, and the fair use is also strict
liability. Now, I would still include those statements in the
brief. I still think they're stupid statements, but there is
no absolutely no reason to think that the president coming out
of this would at all be limited to what Ethan is claiming, I
think, disingenuously that this is what it's about, which is
it's going after people who are intentional because I stress
again, it's not about purpose. It's not or sorry, intentionality.
It is about purpose and character of the work, but it's from
an objective uh perspective. It's not from your subjective intent
to steal money or not steal money. That is not an element in
the underlying fair use or in the underlying uh infringement.
So, so that's what I'm saying is that anyone who would expect
that precedent in any kind of dispositive emotion practice here
would turn on this issue of quote unquote malice and intentional
typing is deranged. It's deranged to think that what's it's going
to it's just as likely to produce precedent that narrows the
scope of what the status quo is these this day and age. It's
going to narrow I feel like I feel like he's speaking very in
very coach terms. I don't I don't think it's just as likely.
I think it's far more likely to generate a precedent that narrows
reaction content that narrows the the scope of or the extent
to which react react content can freely be done the amount of
react reactions that can occur because probably a lot more reactions
are infringing than people think and that's true because Ethan
acknowledges that because XQC and as gold people who he says
he wants to protect he acknowledges that they're infringing and
that's what doesn't make sense to me about this entire thing.
Why would you say that you're trying to protect that which you
call an injustice? He starts the video. I want to repeat. He
You literally cannot set some precedent for malice being a factor
here. That is not something you can do. I mean, I don't believe
it's a Pesco seems to be hedging. So maybe I should hedge, too.
It seems incredibly unlikely that they would read that and and
read, you know, some element of malice into the law that doesn't
exist there, that isn't explicitly written. It's a federal statute.
I believe federal statutes are supposed to be read even more
like like from a textual point of view. You cannot read things
into a federal statute that aren't there. From what I understand,
start the video by saying the people who do these long views
of content, not just people who have a stated intentional malicious
intent or whatever. It's people who watch this long thing without
being transformative. He calls that theft and he calls that an
injustice. And he says that XQC is a prime suspect. And he and
he talks about ReactGate. And you remember where Ethan Klein
was during Reactate. And during ReactGate, he was saying that
this was wrong what XUC was doing. And so it doesn't make sense
for us to think that what he's actually trying to do is protect
XQC and Asmin Gold and these types. And that's one of the reasons
why he's doing this is to protect those guys because he's been
on record attacking them. I don't think he was I I don't think
he meant to say like, oh, I'm trying to protect specifically
Asmin Gold and XQC. I think he was trying to say, I'm trying
to protect the larger community because if it goes on the way
that it's been going on with these like loose or no standards
whatsoever, then the potential for something much more consequential
becomes more likely down the line. Um the moment that we're in
right now, I think with React stuff is very similar to the moment
that gaming content was in when I came up on YouTube back in
2008, 2009. Um people just started uploading gaming videos and
uh there were very like Nintendo was a company that they still
might do it. They used to do a lot of like takedowns for any
that kind of limitation with reach media reviewers with titles
like I watch this so you don't have to. Yeah, that is a point
we had brought up earlier which is yeah lots of people say that
I watch this so you don't have to and they give the review. Right.
the the intentionality of the review doesn't really seem to impact
their whether or not it's uh fair use any kind of gameplay whatsoever.
And uh then a company named Machinima came along and all of a
sudden we started monetizing like gaming gaming content even
though we did not have the when did did Hutch just become counterpoints?
He's going to do a personal story that has like nothing to do
with anything and just like ramble about nothing for minutes.
This is this has got to go. I don't need, dude. Elizabeth Warren
and her consequences, okay, have been disastrous for the human
race.
This is the first person I ever noticed who does this who's like
in the middle of like a consequential debate on something and
will rattle off a completely unrelated story for no reason that
I don't care about. Everybody who does this needs to go. They
need to like have their internet taken away. You shouldn't be
able to do this. Okay? Just stick on topic. Don't tell a totally
unrelated story that takes minutes to tell for the love of God.
the rights to like upload this content. Um, and so there was
like a bit of tension I think in the beginning between like gaming
creators and the gaming studios that actually publish the pub
or the publishers that publish the games. But what ended up happening
is like I still don't think there's any like legal clarity on
that. It's just that the publishers came to the conclusion I
think correct conclusion that having creators upload videos of
their games actually benefits them because it's like free advertising.
So like so they just decide not to enforce these rules. Um, with
the with the React stuff, I think it's a little bit different
because a lot of times with the React stuff, you know, you're
you're reacting to um I don't know if I can articulate why it's
different. Can we linearize a little bit? So, let's linearize
a little bit. So, you agree that that Ethan is presenting that
there's an existential risk to the community. He is presenting
that there's an existential risk with respect to outside. Yeah.
reactor when when reactors don't make any kind of good faith
effort whatsoever to have the work be transformative but in the
particular egregious case of like denims and took it even a step
further and announces their stated goal to like let's linearize
you agree that he says that there's an existential threat to
the reaction community right yeah do you agree with that well
I Pisco does agree that there's a threat he just doesn't agree
that it's denims and fro I do think potentially there is and
there's a one of the reasons there's an ex existential threat
to the react community is because a lot of react community is
infringing they're not fair use it's infringement. So what the
react community does not transformative
it's well transformative is is one of the ways that you can achieve
fair use status right it can be transformative um or it could
fulfill any of the other factors uh transformative is most associated
with purpose and character of the work as one of the four factors
of but it's not the only thing you look to to fair use but all
of what's going on in the reaction community there's probably
a ton of in of infringement going on there that's not fair use
right and by definition not fair use and so I believe that there
probably is a looming threat from rights holders with respect
to a lot of the react because a lot of the React community is
infringing. And so I agree that he's he's setting that out and
he's saying that one of the reasons why I'm choosing to sue and
establish a precedent on fair use of reaction content is actually
to protect from Sony and Disney. That is so delusional as to
be disingenuous. If you establish a precedent on uh fair use
of reaction videos, it's going to be more narrow. It's going
to be more narrow than what the content reaction community is
doing right now. Almost certainly. It's not going to um it's
not going to be on this line of people whose stated intent is
to steal money. Imagine if that were the test, right? Imagine
a court said, "Oh, all of this is okay as long as you say I as
long as you don't say you want to steal money from these people."
That is obviously not what's going to happen. Like imagine if
all it took for you to pass the fair use muster for whatever
president is to start out your video say no no uh no infringement
intended. No infringement intended at all. Like that's not what
the court's going to say because that don't matter. And everyone
knows it. If they look in their heart of hearts, they know the
court's not going to be like, "Okay, what's what's really going
to turn our precedent is whether or not the people individually
have good intent or bad intent or want to steal or don't want
to steal because it's not an element and it's not relevant if
you say nothing intended. Please, you know, if you link to the
Disney Plus, if you link to the Sony video, that doesn't matter
if you're trying to push your audience towards them. It's infringement.
It's infringement. It's infringement. So, it's not going to be
the case that any kind of precedent that that Ethan turns out
is going to drive on this distinction. That's why he's lying
about that or at least he's so diluted that it's the equivalent
of lying. He's No, he's just lying. He's like obviously lying.
He obviously knows this to be the case. He's obviously been talking
to a lawyer about suing these people for a long time, right?
He doesn't care. He He just transparently does not give up lying
about that in my opinion or being disingenuous about it. And
what's really happening is he's trying to shield himself by being
what he's presented himself as, which is the defender of fair
use, the defender of copyright, which he he was principled before
from what? from criticism because he knows that the people who
are like XQC and Asmin Gold are popular and he doesn't want XQC
and Asminold or their communities to think that their creators
are at risk and so he wants his targets that is the unpopular
people. um he wants everyone to be on board against them and
that's why he invents this rationale of this is about protecting
the broader community when the fact is any generated precedent
is uh also yes a whole bunch of this entire thing is just for
social media and just for content way more than I thought before
really he is hoping these people will settle as well he doesn't
want to follow it through on basically any of these he is hoping
people settle he's doing this for content and while he's doing
for content he doesn't want to piss off XQC's community doesn't
want to piss off Asmin Gold's He doesn't want to off any of these
really big reactors who are actually causing harm. So, he won't
be suing them. That's why he just wants these communities on
his side and he knows if he's suing Caseyron and not suing XC
or Asminold, he's got a huge chunk of community and fan base
that will not go after him is not going to be limited to the
kind of non-element that he's pointed to, which is the stated
intention. And also, he's claiming to try to protect something
that he says is an injustice, which is he calls what XC did an
injustice even without the stated militia's intent. So, that's
my point. No, but No, but I think you're Okay. Well, I think
you're taking him I think you're I think you're misinterpreting
what he's saying because like I I think I've said it a couple
times, but like I don't think he's saying because I don't think
he's saying I want to protect XQC and Asmin Gold's ability to
keep doing what they're doing. Then why does he say I would never
sue them? Why would he say I would never sue them? Because I
wouldn't want to tell the reaction. Why would he say that? I
I think it's because the potential the potential outcome of him
going after like XQC and Asmin like would you agree for example
or like let's use the Sony example like don't don't you think
there's more of a risk of
an we'll call it like overcorrection or don't you think there's
more of a risk of a of an of a ruling that um greatly limits
the ability to react to the extent that people maybe don't even
want to do it cuz they don't want to risk any kind of litigation.
Like, don't you think that's more likely if the lawsuit comes
from a company like Sony than than an individual creator like
Ethan? No, I think an individual creator like Ethan is most likely
to create bad precedent. And the reason I think that is because
the big companies like Sony and Disney um the big companies like
Sony and Disney might not waste their time going after Denims
when Denims had a substantial reaction, right? They might go
after Casey Tron. They might go after people who are but because
Ethan is going at some after somebody who had a substantial reaction,
he is opening up and making that precedent far more likely. That
will be something that has to be litigated based on his lawsuit
against Adams. That has to be litigated
exactly how fair use it is to do a transformative commentary
over a long form video in its entirety in one piece in one stream.
That has to be litigated for a decision to be made on Denim's
case. There is just no other way around it. And her her reaction
is substantial enough that many of the popular reactors like
XQC are going to be caught up in that precedent no matter what.
Right? If it was like Disney or something, they might only go
after, let's say, the XQC. They might only go after Casey Tron.
They might go after something where they're like guaranteed to
win, right? They might try to set a precedent first. They might
be strategic. They might try to set a precedent first against
people who are just reacting with no commentary, who are just
like kind of doing like facial reactions with with a chat over
on the side of the screen and see how that goes. They might be
strategic about it, right? Ethan is malicious. He he hates these
people. He's just going after whoever he can for whatever like
anything he remotely can. And so he is going to set a bad precedent
because he doesn't care. When often times they go after Littlefish,
they, you know, they might sue or they might just get a settlement
and they must, they enforce their copyright by setting a precedent
that they're going to, you know, start to sue or they'll send
you a cease and desist letter or they'll use a DMCA, right? Um
but it very rarely goes to any kind of opinion, but where where
we can get like clear one of the reasons why we're not getting
clear precedent on these issues is because these big organizations,
it never gets really to um an actual merit's opinion. But someone
who's motivated by spite, not by money, and who really wants
to make it hurt, we're more likely to get a merit's opinion,
which is damaging, from an Ethan Klein who doesn't care about
money, doesn't care really about the underlying infringement,
and just want to make it hurt, then someone like Sony or Disney
who, yeah, okay, you take down the content and word spreads naturally,
don't with Sony, don't with Disney, and it's very unlikely those
cases go actually to a merit's opinion. And so, I totally disagree.
I think we're more likely to get bad precedent from someone acting
out of spite and who's willing to go the distance than someone
like Sony or Disney where they haven't really shown that tendency.
I just don't think Ethan and his lawyers are going to argue the
case in the way that might steer towards something like that.
And the other thing too is like Ethan does react content. So
like I don't understand the you know he obviously doesn't want
to completely stifle his ability to do that himself. So he doesn't
care. He doesn't care. He doesn't care. Yeah.
So I I think that what he what he is doing um is likely to result
if it were to go to kind of merit's opinion on a dispositive
motion to dismiss or on summary judgement. What would likely
happen is you would have a a narrowing of what's allowed um under
these kinds of react, you know, genre, whatever. And people are
unlikely to sue Ethan because in general, these people, like
you said, the rights holders aren't as latigious as people expected.
And so Ethan isn't seriously expecting a lawsuit from like Sony
or Disney or any of these other content creators because they
know that the the litigation expenses is such a barrier that
often times people don't give a and so he like he's not really
worried about these other rights holders. He's worried about
making these people hurt and protecting himself from criticism.
And that's why he has to put in the savior rationale. When you
say when you say protecting himself from criticism, what do you
mean? I mean protecting himself from the Asmin Gold or XQC community
um who might be fearful that what he's doing if he didn't distinguish
them, right? If he didn't come up with some pretext uh that that
they'd be like, "Hey, hang on a second. We we this is fair use."
He wants those people on his side and so he wants to be like,
"No, no, this is different. This is different. This is different."
And it is different. I'll grant him it is different, but it's
not different. Yeah. I would say the reason he names XQC and
says he doesn't want to chill XQC or Asmin Gold is explicitly
to keep those people on his side that like Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
I thought So the point I was making and you make a stronger point
like Pisco is making here. The point I was previously making
was he doesn't sue them because then they that community would
be against him but Pisco is saying well he names them and says
he won't sue them explicitly because he wants their uh their
support in all of this. Yeah, it's probably true um in the sense
of the outcome for president and it's not different in justifying
rationale which is that he wants to protect people like XC and
Asmin Gold or he wants to not kill them when he himself says
it's an injustice. What would be an appropriate um rationale
for him to provide is saying I'm going after these people because
they're the worst of the worst. That's why I'm going after them.
If he just said that fine, I wouldn't have a problem with that.
But if he said I'm going after these people because of the worst
of the worst and because I want to protect you. I want to protect
the reaction community. I want to protect people like XC and
Asminold and I want to protect all these reactors. That's what
I have a problem with. Not him going after them because the worst
of the worst, but him going after them because I want to protect
you. that is what I take to be disingenuous and it's not and
and I want you and I to agree on that. I mean, in what respect
do you think that he's gonna he's actually trying to protect
the React community? How could you ever grant him that? I could
grant him that because he has a history of wanting to protect
creators for he has he has a he has an established history like
on the record of saying that he thinks that the way that a lot
of React stuff happens is completely unfair to the creator. Why
would he want to Is Hutch Is Hutch a robot? Is Hutch a robot?
He's like he's having a Marco Rubio moment. Okay. He's being
asked to like integrate new information and update it and he
just keeps going with the same script from
And then also the like think about it this way like if he did
sue Asmin Gold and XQC for the kind of react that they that they
do it would chill the React community. Like a lot of people would
stop reacting to the content. So is this so would this I don't
think. No, no, no. Like when I uh Pisco really needs to hammer
home the point that malice is not an element of fair use. Malice
is not an element of like intentionality is not an element of
fair use. Intentionality is not an element of copyright infringement.
That it does not matter that you cannot set precedent on malice.
That is like incredibly I don't know how you could do it like
theoretically, but it is incredibly unlikely that you could have
this written into the law in any way. That would be that would
almost certainly not fly,
right? But a whole bunch of people are trying to say, well, no,
like it would it would chill the React community if he sued XQC.
It would kill the React community significantly less if he sued
XQC than suing Frogan. That's just facts. When I saw this, I
didn't think to myself, sorry, not Frogan, not Frogan, Denims,
Denims. I meant Denim. I saw the whole video. I didn't think
to myself, well, maybe I don't want to do any kind of React content.
Like, I can only speak to my experience, but what I what I did
kind of immediately was just sort of like re-evaluate. Like,
I think I'm already like pretty decent about this stuff anyways,
but there's just there's just going to be certain things that
I do every single time from now on that maybe I didn't before
to sort of add that extra layer like of protection. But this
action that he took against like Denims and Frogan, that didn't
make me like want to stop reacting to stuff. If he would have
gone after like you linking the This is another important thing.
You linking the video and saying, "Guys, go support them." That
doesn't mean that you didn't create a market replacement. That
is not the case. Okay? You can't just do that and your intention
to like, oh well guys, I really don't want to in I really want
to help them by not commenting over this and not transforming
at all. Like that does doesn't matter. Doesn't matter. It would
make you want to stop. Isn't intentionality taken into consideration
during damages? Uh, it couldn't possibly be taken into consideration
for damages in most cases or sorry in the non in the non- Congress
Library of Congress case. Okay. Because it's actual damages.
It could be taken to account for statutory damages. But we'll
see. But why? But why? Probably. No, no. This is this is um it
it is proof of willful intentionality, but I willful intentionality
is a very easy bar to clear. This is why hush because you know
he's not he doesn't really care about the infringement. He doesn't
really care about the statements. He cares about going after
these people. That's why you don't feel any fear. You don't feel
any fear because you don't have a vendetta against Ethan. But
if you did have a vendetta against Ethan and let me let me tell
you people who don't have a good relationship or don't like H3
or don't have like a positive relationship with them, I'm sure
they feel chilled. I'm sure. Right. You would agree with that,
right? People who don't have like a positive Yes, dude. You can
sound like such an informed intelligent creator by just going
like literally train had it from the very beginning. Okay. literally
just reverse the roles in any given situation and see how your
thinking changes and you suddenly become like a thousand times
better than almost every every like creator who comments on things.
Hey, well, I kind of like Ethan Klein, but how would I feel about
this if I didn't like Ethan Klein? If I was critical of Ethan
Klein, how would I feel about this? Oh, this probably make me
feel like pretty concerned. Oh. Oh. Oh my god. Positive relationship
with Ethan. They're probably feeling chill. How long has it been
since Queman spoke last? I can't remember. Oh, fun fact. Sometimes
when he's here, uh, he tells me he's going to go and then I just
slip a different overlay in that still shows him here. So that
like there's like, you know, good chunk of people who like hearing
on the stream. I just pretend he's here. Okay. After he falls
asleep. Yeah. He's not there. He he can't even speak right now.
Killed about reviewing his content. Wouldn't you?
Let me first first let me clarify like the the reason why I don't
feel chilled is because I know that I have never done what Froggen
and Denims and they did. I've never said like, "Hey guys, watch
it here so we can take a video a view away from the creator."
Like, I never took it to that extent. That that's why I didn't
feel any fear. Not because I felt like um not not because he's
maybe only going after them because of like you don't feel fear
because Ethan's not going to go after you. You feel fear because
the precedent he's setting can't possibly include the malice.
Has to be over how transformative things are. And if he sets
a narrowing precedent, then probably if you're critical of people,
you're you're potentially open to infringement in a lot of cases,
like personal grievance. So, so when he he he planned the trap
before they made those admissions, right? So, he planned his
quote unquote trap before he could have known that these people
were giving admissions, right? Um, yes. And before how can we
say that this whole thing was about this specific subset of infringement
if he couldn't have known when he started this trap, right? He
registered with the copyright office before those admissions
were made. Because they've been doing this. No, no, but this
isn't the first time they've done this. They've they keep they
they do this all the time with him specifically. Wait, they do
what all the time? They do. They actually dude Caseyron does
this with like actually Disney and Okay. The thing where they
play it on their stream so you don't so you don't give him a
view where they've made where they've made the admission before.
Yeah. Well, I haven't seen that. I haven't seen where they made
the admissions before. I've seen the admissions with respect.
Can we get a link? Can we get a link content? But he couldn't.
Okay. But okay, but they No, but they've done it before. That's
why he was able to predict they were going to do it. So you actually
do think that he was predicting that they were going to make
these kinds of self-s serving statements and he planned from
the start machavellingly that they would make these specific
statements saying watch it with me so that we steal money from
him. He he he planned that they would that's what he claims after
the fact. I honestly don't know if I even believe him that I
don't believe Oh. So you think that he's probably lying about
setting up a trap? Maybe. Yeah. For for for content for the memes.
Dude, h how do you argue with somebody who does this? I don't
I don't know if I don't know if he actually set a trap. I could
be wrong. So that's what I don't understand. I have what? What
do you even say there? He just said nothing. He started making
a statement. Had Pisco like say, "Oh, so you're saying this?"
And he's like, "Wait, no, never mind. I don't know. I actually
There's no way to know." Uh um uh uh uh. Right. Like why? I'm
much more willing to believe that he was actually registering
his copyright like with a specific intention. Did he do that
before he posted the video or did he do it after the fact? Yes.
He could you hear me hit my own forehead there with my palm,
guys? Could you hear it? cuz holy well he he registered the the
whatever the stream is after but he registered his his nuke beforehand
um and the comp
he was planning on suing and he really couldn't have known that
these people were going to issue these statements and and here's
a question for you right so imagine but you keep ignoring but
they've done it before this is like this is repeat behavior for
them this is not new for them they're so malicious to Ethan and
they've been malicious for over years no where they specifically
were going to say that I task thinks Hutch won this debate by
the way sure very smart guy want to siphon views and content
from this specific video. Anything with this in his mind?
Oh, Straight Ray just asked a fantastic con uh question in Pisco's
chat. If this was a pattern, if this was so prevalent and apparently
they do it all the time, then where exactly are the other clips
that Ethan could have included to show that they do this more
often, to show that they've had like a Where where is that in
the lawsuits to show that they've done this maliciously before
for things he hadn't registered? That sure seems like it would
be helpful to include in these lawsuits. No. Hey, this isn't
the first time they actually did this against me. Yes, especially
the Snark. The Snark for sure will link like mirror links so
that it doesn't give him a view because I know for a fact Snark
the subreddit they went out of their way for a long time. I'm
talking about the principal infringement here because you need
an underlying infringement for the contributotory theory if you
can even have the contributotory theory at all. But for the underlying
uh situation if Denims had not said what she said about watch
it with me and not with anyone else. Do you think it would have
suited her? I don't know. I maybe not a thousand% he would have
a thousand%
he would have done this. Maybe what's the most likely he would
have he would have just gone down the line. He would have said
because of CPS. He would have done it if he had to. He would
have gone because of CPS. He would have said it. We all know
he would have said it. Or or if Casey Tron had said had not said
what she said, "Yeah, watch it with me." Or whatever she said
or broken the same thing. Do you think they would have sued him?
Do you think he would have sued them? I It's impossible to put
myself in his head. I really don't know. But I I
uh Wait, Hutch, weren't you literally just putting yourself in
his head when you were commenting on whether or not he was telling
the truth or playing it up for like setting his trap? Didn't
you get in his head there to defend him? And now when Pisco's
like, "Hey, get in his head right here." H like, "Oh, I couldn't
possibly couldn't possibly get in his head." Okay. Couldn't possibly
do that. I think probably not. Like if I'm if I'm if I'm treating
him in good faith, then probably not. Like cuz if he would have
if he would have Think about that for a second. game out that
game out that game plan though. Like if he if he were originally
intending just to sue anybody who reacted to the video, then
that would have necessarily included people like XQC and Asold.
And then like I and I think he knows that that would not have
been publicly um supported because it, you know, it nobody made
that claim. Hutch is addressing a claim that nobody has made.
Nobody actually cares about this. Potentially would have transformed
React content to the extent that maybe people didn't even do
it. Why? Why? Why? Why? So, so I I think that for example, imagine
that imagine that Hassan just did what uh Frogan did. You think
he wouldn't have sued Hassan?
Ask that question again. I didn't understand. Imagine that Hassan
did what Frogan did but never said, "I'm trying to steal money
from Ethan." You think he would have? Do you think he would have
sued Hassan? I think the answer is obviously he would have. He
was planning this to sue and he could not have relied on his
targets in the specific instances making these kinds of admissions.
He couldn't have relied on it. His plan was much greater than
that. And the fact that he was saying watch it, watch it, watch
it, watch it, I think lends more to the notion that this was
a trap and that he was being honest about it being a trap. He's
being dishonest about it. This was all we're this was a Mchavelling
strategy to actually help protect the community from Sony and
Disney. That my intention, my my motivation was to protect the
reaction community when I set this trap because it would require
him knowing in advance or having planned that these people were
going to make these damning admissions when there's no room.
You're dismissing But you're dismissing the fact that they had
already done this kind of stuff before. I can't speak to each
individual creator, but I know for a fact that like the Snark
subreddit, which is like very much kind of Oh. Oh, he's talking
about the Snark subreddit. This is so stupid. You have Okay,
as Piso said, you have to prove the underlying uh what the underlying
infringement to get to other contributors towards it. But even
then, you also have to prove that they have coordinated in some
way, right? that Denims had any idea what was going on there.
That Denims was not just benefiting but like set herself up to
benefit in some way, right? Good lord. Overlaps with all these
So, so this is just an admission that when he said, "Oh, these
people have done this before." That was just a lie. That was
just a total lie. The Snark subreddit was absolutely regularly
doing this exact thing. Um, and so maybe he maybe he originally
was uh was was intent was intending to target the snark which
which there's there's press there's but there would need to be
an underlying infringement. There would need to be an underline
infringement that he goes after. And if you're saying that's
what I'm saying is that they they they had done it over and over
again. They do the the mirror links with the with the message
on the top of the equal. Don't give Ethan a view. Watch it here.
Gun to your head. Everything is same about Frogan's reaction.
Everything's same about the snark. But Frogan doesn't make those
statements. We still have all of the snark. Do you think that
he would have sued Frogan? No, I don't. I I think that that's
crazy. I think that that's completely crazy to say. I think why
would you think that's crazy? Because they all pretext to that
the notion that so so when Hutch said like oh when Pisco asked
what you've sued these people and Hut Hutch goes no no they declared
that they wanted to do this before he is not suing the Snarkers.
They are I think they are elements or they are what do you call
it? They're they're a part of that lawsuit but I do not believe
in his prayer for relief he's he's seeking damages from the Snark
community. Right. I don't think so. I think it'll be like he's
he's listing them as not participants. What is it? I can't remember
what what the word is exactly, but he he has like the what the
10 mods listed in the Denims lawsuit. I don't think he's seeking
damages from them. Are they codependents? I don't know.
I I'm just not sure. I don't think he's seeking damages from
them. I think he's seeking to get like information on them to
subpoena them or something. Right.
like he's suing Denims. He is trying to get money from Denims.
Denims did not make these statements. There was no way he would
know that Denim would make the Denims would make these statements,
which is the question Pisco asked. How did he know that Denims
was going to make this statement? Oh, she like they made these
statements before. I don't know about each individual one, but
they had. And then it comes down to It's like, oh, the Snark
people had not one of the primary um defendants in these. He's
actually trying to enforce this this standard on the community
that is turning on an issue that's not relevant or uh or not
even one of the elements of the underlying infringement and that
it's all about this particular kind of infringement is all a
pretext. It's all obviously a sham. The notion that he's trying
to protect infringement at all. Why would he try to protect infringement?
Why would you protect infringement? He's trying to protect fair
use trying to protect He is trying to protect infringement. know
he he says right
the entire the entirety of the 2023 react gate stuff was saying
XQC is infringing it is not fair use what you do is not fair
use XQC did the thing that Ethan complained about during 2023
react gate to Ethan with this video and Ethan said he did not
want to chill that kind of reaction Ethan is so
he's so bass backwards on this okay he's so on this that he literally
took the thing that he took a principled stance and decided that
he said, "Oh, I I don't want to chill that, guys. I don't want
to chill that. Listen, guys. I don't want to do that."
It's just so cool that XC was kind enough to not react, to say,
"I'm not even reacting. I'm just watching." And then for his
YouTube editor to go take that VOD, not do anything with it.
Um, grab the thumbnail from Ethan, put XQC's Pogf face in the
corner, and then re-upload it with essentially the exact same
title. So cool. So cool. I could go after a lot of people, but
I wouldn't want to chill them. No, I think he is he is hoping
that through this action it it causes people like XQC and Hassan
and Asmin Gold to adopt better standards. So why does he why
doesn't he DMCA XQC then? Um because again you're I think you're
ignoring the idea that like if he were to go after people like
XC and Asma for the kind of rea
if he car
because it's because with XQC it's infringement.
Yes. He he does he's explicitly saying he is saying these people
infringed on my copyright and they declared malicious intent.
That's why I'm going after them. Okay. But there are other infringers
who he has said I don't want to chill. Why is he saying I don't
want to chill infringement. Uh I couldn't log in for a while
but hearing Ter, you know, he wants to debate Quean. Uh I would
moderate that but I don't think um I don't know if he's actually
going to do it. Cared about if he cared about enforcing good
standards, why wouldn't he just he doesn't have to sue XT? Why
doesn't he just DMC XC? Because I think he's specifically targeting
this malicious behavior. No, but and by targeting the malicious
behavior, I think he can he thinks he can incidentally incentivize
better behavior for Yes. Why? Why would he say I would never
sue XQC? So how is he trying in what realm is he trying to change
behavior when he says I would never sue him? You keep saying
he would never sue XQC. He was saying he would never sue XQC
for what XQC blatant infringement would have a chilling effect.
No, but there's a difference though. Like if if XQC took it to
the extent that like Denims did, then I could see. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait. So XQC, I really wish Pisco would just Pisco,
he doesn't even have to watch the whole Denim's reaction. He
should just be like aware of how misrepresented it is and the
difference. He should have the talking point of like, you understand
that Denim's added more than double the runtime to the content
nuke than XQC did. And she pushed back in several places. She
was providing critical commentary, right? XQC did not at all.
XQC is a totally willful infringer. He said as much to Ethan's
face and then despite them having that debate in 2023, he did
everything he did was criticized for in 2023 to Ethan. And then
Ethan says, "I don't want to chill that guy. I don't want to
chill that kind of commentary." But it makes no sense. Makes
no sense at all. Has a lot more transform a lot less transformative
stuff than what Denims did. But there wasn't that malicious.
Yeah, but that's not an element that's an element of the underline
infringement. But let's just be clear on something, right? He
he says that he would never sue XQC. So, do you agree with me
that he's not trying to change XC's behavior by suing this? I
don't agree with you. No, I don't agree with you. I think he
is I think he is trying to I think he is trying to change the
If he's trying to change behavior, why doesn't he condemn what
XC did? Why doesn't he condemn what XC did in the video? But
he said he wouldn't he would kill people. But not but but wouldn't
that be like if he was trying to change XQC's behavior,
why would he say I would never sue him? I would Is Pisco going
to give a time stamp or actual quote? He did. He literally did.
In fact, I want to promote what they do. Not a fan of the chatters
in his chat. Your framing is just so incorrect here. He's not
saying literally he would never sue XQC. He's saying he would
never sue XQC for doing what XQC was doing. If XQC did what Denims
did, then he probably would have sued XQC. But he's trying to
I I understand. I don't I really don't want you to bring up the
difference between XQC and Denims again in the sense of uh one
having the most potential. It's not crucial to what I am saying.
All right. I am not talking I acknowledge that he could say I
go after the worst of the worst. What doesn't make sense is I'm
trying to go after the worst of the worst to protect the bad.
That is what doesn't make sense. He is saying he's not protecting
the bad. Yes, he is. He's saying I No, he has actually literally
said XQC is bad. XC is bad. I don't want to This is what he says.
I don't want to kill the reaction community and fear.
Sorry. Sorry. I'll go back. He says, "I could use a lot sue a
lot more creators and rake in millions of dollars, but the purpose
of this that is the lawsuit is not financial gain. People like
XQC and Adminold may have watched the entire thing. They infringed,
definitely infringed, right? But I would never sue them. Sue
them for what infringement that they absolutely did just for
infringing. For infringing, right? I don't want to chill the
reaction community into fear actually." Well, why would suing
infringing content chill the reaction community of non-infringers
into into fear? He's trying to protect infringers, isn't he?
No, I don't agree with you at all. I think this I what is happening.
He doesn't want to chill. So, he is going to go after somebody.
I would say probably with Denim's thing, she's possibly,
it's very possible she's not infringing. I don't know that it's
like uh even like a sub 10% chance. That was me hitting my forehead
with my palms. Right-wing lunatic. Okay. Um I don't even know
that it's like less than a 10%. Like, I really think there's
an argument for Denims that she might she might be able to get
like a fair use consideration. He is going after somebody who
transformed his work very very obviously. There is no carve out
in it. There is no element of these things that it that takes
into account intent. He cannot sue for intent. He can say that's
how I pick my targets. But he is ultimately suing somebody who
is very much transformative in every sense in the current culture
suing her. Okay.
And that could set a precedent that would affect XQC and all
these other people. He is still chilling XQC,
right? I think that's what Pisco should be arguing is like he
says he doesn't want to chill them, but he is looking for a precedent
that would chill. You watch Denim stream on the content nuke.
No, that's going to it's going to be so boring. I didn't watch
the content nuke. Why the would I want to watch Denim stream
on the content nuke? What? Why? Why would I want to do that?
I can't think of something I The content nuke itself was already
so unbelievably boring. Why the would I want to watch a comment
over it? Framing is I'm not gonna call you dishonest. I just
think you have the wrong Sorry. I just I really don't want to
watch it. I've never wanted to watch it. I don't want to I don't
care framing here. Like, first of all, do we even agree? I can
see that they're arguing that she had to lie or misrepresent
things. They literally pull out a bunch of her transformative
commentary. Right. You said it was transformative. You could
see it's transformative from the people who are supposed to be
arguing it's not transformative from their legal document. You
can see it's transformative, right? I don't have to watch it.
I've watched the people who have to make the strongest argument
that it's not transformative. Literally give me all the proof
that it's transformative. If they can't argue that it's not transformative,
who can
that if he were to sue Asmin and XQC for what they did, which
is like which is which is not malicious in the sense that they
said that they wanted to seal views, but just I don't I can't
speak to Asma, but for XQC, like there was basically no effort
whatsoever to be transformative. And this is kind of like a regular
thing. Like, do you agree that suing them for that would actually
chill the community? It would chill infringement. It would chill
bad infringement. It would do what Ethan has said he stood up
for this whole time and was arguing against that he called it
injustice. He started the video by saying that kind of thing,
that specific thing that you just referenced, what XC did. He
called that theft and an injustice. So, yeah, I think it would
chill in injustice, which is what he says he wants to that's
why he was arguing with XC that entire time in that. you say
chilled, what we mean is people might be less inclined to do
any kind of React content, even if their work was way more transformative
than XQC's for fear of like, well, I don't know the implications
of where this is going and I just don't want to expose myself
to any kind of You don't think Okay, so if that's what he's trying
to say, you think that that's true of his current lawsuit that
people won't overcorrect based on the current lawsuit? Not nearly
to the extent that I think they would if
the only reason why people because he because he because he laid
out like really specific elements for what he thinks is like
malicious. First of all, who the is he? Who the [__]
is he to impose that standard of infringement on the broader
community? So, are you telling me that he would criticize someone
who sued? So, let's say someone's in a similar position and someone,
this is the question, right, Hutch? So, imagine that XUC does
that reaction of another content creator and someone sued XQC
for doing that reaction? Not malicious reaction, but like full
on what he he did, right? Would he condemn that person for suing
XC for infringement? I have no idea. But the the thing is if
he if to be consistent, right, he would have to say yeah, he
would condemn it. Why would he condemn it? Because suing XQC
for doing what XQC does would chill the reaction community, right?
So if someone else sued XQC,
in order to be consistent on his rationale, he's got to say,
"Why are you suing XQC?" Don't you know that suing XQC will improperly
chill the reaction community? That's
I think it's conceivable that he would have that position that
like if he were to talk about it on his podcast, for example,
brother, brother, brother, it's conceivable that he would be
like potentially really scare a lot of people from doing any
React content. So you think it's conceivable that after Ethan
spent so much time in the past critiquing the XC saying he's
courting disaster, saying what he's doing is an injustice, saying
that what he's doing is theft, that when some He literally Ethan
literally like explained how his position was correct. Like he
he literally is referencing his own 2023 position. One tries
to remedy the injustice. You think it's conceivable that past
Ethan would say this is wrong. I disagree with with the lawsuit
against XQC, which is obviously injustice, which obviously theft.
Because even though you're suing to prevent an injustice, it
will improperly chill, impermissibly chill the rest of the fair
use reaction community that he would actually condemn a lawsuit
if someone, you know, uh, ratifying their their their rights,
their and preventing the theft of XQC that he would actually
condemn them as being corrosive to the reaction community. You
think he would possibly do that? I do think it's conceivable
because even if you're going after something that you perceive
to be an injustice, you could also make an internal calculation
that by going after that thing, you could do more harm than good.
Again,
I I wish there was any
h is doing that by going after Denims, right?
XQC's conduct is far worse than Denim's conduct with respect
to the actual law. Far worse. And he is going to force a ruling
on that or he's willing to force a ruling on that. But that's
not really a difficult to reconcile. I'm not saying that it's
logically impossible to hold those beliefs. I guess that you
could say that what's going on is bad, but remedying it is worse.
I think it's preposterous to think that. So, for example, let's
say that XQC did what he did and some rights holders let's say
that he watched the full episode of um the bull work or something
or or one of these political shows and then the bull work sues
XQC. Do you think that he would and but all XQC did was literally
look at the screen and be like, "Wow, that's crazy, man. Wow,
that's crazy, man." And the bull work sues XQC. Do you think
he would say, "Why is the bull work doing this? What the They're
going to chill the community." Well, I don't know about that
specific language, but it's entirely conceivable to me that he
would like Let's Dude,
why why would Hutch do this to himself?
That I guess the the question would be, do you think that there
is a difference in the eyes of the law in what like basically
Frogan did and what XQC does or what what Caseyron did and what
XQC does? Do you think there's a difference in the eyes of the
law? Because there is essentially no difference, right, between
the two. Okay,
he is suing Frogan literally 2025. Ethan doesn't even believe
this position at all. What is Hutch trying to argue? Say he's
talking about it on his podcast like the next day or whatever.
I think it's entirely conceivable that he could say something
to the effect of like I think what XUC is doing is wrong, but
by no action should be but no action should be taken against
him is what you're saying that they would say that. No, no. I
think like you can try to devise an outcome through other means
besides like directly confronting the thing that you're trying
to challenge. And so you could engineer an outcome where people
adopt better standards for React content by doing a more targeted
approach. Let me let me ask like a different question then. Like
do you have examples of Ethan being disingenuous about things
that like you think it's like a part of his character? Like Yeah.
I mean if you're going to accuse someone of being disingenuous,
there should be some sort of like to say like in the past like
they did this one thing. So I I vaguely recall he was a little
bit disingenuous about the Washington Post article at one point
in his career. I recall um there were some aspects of what he
said to Hassan in their debate that I I thought were disingenuous.
I don't recall them precisely, but I I'm not saying that he has
a character for disingenuousness. I'm saying he is being that's
that's up that Hutch would just pull the pin on an anti-semitism
accusation grenade and chuck it at Pisco. Oh, you saying this
guy is uh you saying it's a part of his character there, Pisco,
to for him to be disingenuous, for him to be duplicitous, for
him to lie, for him to be shady, Pisco, is that what you're saying?
disingenuous in this specific thing and I need not they do a
podcast together and he just did that support a broader statement
on his character to support this specific act of disingenuousness
and so no as I sit here I'm not able to provide you specific
moments in the past unrelated to this incident that show he's
being disingenuous I'm only talking about one thing here's the
thing like you I just want to say you could be right about all
of this just to be clear like I don't I I don't know Ethan basically
at all and so all the things that you're saying might be true
I'm I'm offering an alternative perspective that there is a universe
where he could care about both of these things at the same time
where you know he's denim for what she did about the CPS thing
and all these other creators for piling on after his family got
called on CBS and maybe that's the primary thing that's driving
this thing but I don't think that that necessarily means and
I don't know if this is what you're saying but I don't think
this this necessarily means that he's not genuine in his hopes
to sort of uh like foster a better like cultural set of standards
for React content like this is what you have to this is and I'm
trying to represent the position that you're you're saying is
conceivable that Ethan does condemn what XQC and Asminold do.
He thinks it is wrong, but he thinks that remedying what they
do by either issuing a DMCA takedown or uh doing some kind of
lawsuit against them that that would be really bad because it
would impermissibly chill the fair use of the reaction community
in a way that's different than what would be chilled for his
lawsuit. And that the precedent produced by his lawsuit has a
much higher chance of being more tailored and specific to malicious
intent style um uh infringement and not non-malicious intent
style infringement. even though the vast majority of infringement
doesn't have explicit malicious intent in it and that he thinks
that Sony and Disney are more likely to or less likely to come
and intervene in the reaction community if the standard of not
having explicit malicious intent is enforced by him. That to
me is such a preposterous set of beliefs that all of them, right?
The notion that Sony and Disney would give a whether the stated
intention is to siphon or not siphon as opposed to what they
care about which is their bottom line. the notion that he that
he thinks and would have a problem with people DMCA and clear
blatant infringement or suing people for clear blatant infringement
when in the past he has said that that's you know he's been a
supporter of this kind of very balanced approach and the notion
that he thought about this all in advance and this was all part
of his plan. I mean all of that to me is so preposterous and
and it's not plausible. This is what he's thinking. You're you're
suggest literally none of those things are remotely I and here's
the thing. Okay, this is what you should all think of. Okay,
this is what you should all think about. All you need to understand
is one of these people came into this debate with no understanding
of the topic, no understanding of the facts, not knowing anything
about this. Basically, every time they speak, what they say is
false and they're totally on Ethan's side. That's like the level
of knowledge you need to have to be like totally in the tank
for Ethan. you did actually just be a right or totally malicious
one of the two. Suggesting that his original plan was that he
was going to go after any sorry for Ethan's intent. You um you
could think he has strong lawsuit here, right? You could you
could absolutely think he has a strong lawsuit. But I'm saying
if you're defending his like intent like what he's trying to
do here, what what his real goal is in doing this, you're
you're lost, man. You're lost. Oh, and if you're trying to defend
him or if you're trying to say that like oh well like this is
fine. This is um not a problem for broader commentary. This won't
chill things. Yeah, you just you're lost. You're totally lost.
Anybody who reacted to the content in in a sort of XQC manner
and that he changed his mind after the fact to go after
the plausible scenario is he was set in a trap not for anyone
who infringes but for his enemies who infringe. That's the plausible
scenario that he his critics. The people who are critical of
him. Yes, the most critical people. Didn't plan in advance. What's
wrong with that though? I'm not saying that there's anything
wrong with that. Again, I'm not saying there's anything wrong
with that. What I'm saying is don't tell us that this is about
protecting us from Disney and Sony. That's all I'm saying. And
so, when he was making that plan, he never was like, "Well, if
XQC says, yeah, give me give me money. I want the money. Watch
it on my stream." And and this is the question I'll ask you.
If XQC said, uh, you know, watch it on my stream. I want the
money. I want the clicks. Do you think he would say? Uh,
I think that's the interesting one where I feel like almost certainly
he doesn't sue XC if XC says you Ethan, I'm watching this. I
don't think he does. I don't think he does either. I don't think
he does. I think I think he's too calculated to do that. But
I don't know.
I think that would be his initial thing would be he wouldn't
want to sue. But he might end up suing maybe if this was the
only way he could get a rationale that paints him as like the
good guy was like, "Oh, the malicious intent thing." But I don't
think so. I don't think so. Oh, no way. Then I think that's I
think that's completely naive to think that if XC said, you know,
love Ethan, really mean it, but I want the money. I want his
money and so watch it on my stream. If he said that, then uh
I think there's a 0% chance he would go after XC because he doesn't
really care in order to have your like your position. You'd have
to have like a really low opinion of Ethan's character. And I
just don't have that. No, no, no, no. I don't think it requires
me having a bad on his opinion. No, I I in fact I like Ethan
Klein. I've I am have been a big fan of H3 and I uh you know
I watched Vape N. I was a big fan of um Humongous. I I watched
him all throughout his early react days. He's lost his way now,
right? I'm not saying I probably agree more politically with
him than Hassan in terms of lost his way. I don't I don't know
in terms of what that even referred to. I think he has been a
victim of a lot of unfair [__] Um, I certainly don't
support the kind of meandering statements of uh where people
were accusing him of being uh this or that or sending him skulls
or whatever. So, I don't think that he's quote unquote lost his
way. I think that's whatever that means. All I'm saying is that
here he is trying to sell a narrative that doesn't pass muster.
The notion that this is all about protecting from a particular
kind of infringement, but at the same time, we want to not chill
the broader reaction community. And that means not ever taking
action against people like XQC or Asmin Gold, even though what
they do is blatant infringement. Blatant infringement. Um, and
that this is about setting a precedent before Sony and Disney
do, even though there's no absolutely no. Uh, Liboino says, "If
Ethan said, I hate these people and that's why I'm suing them."
I might have I might consider defending him. I still wouldn't
defend him on the Denim's lawsuit because he is he has stated
multiple times he doesn't want to he doesn't want to chill criticism.
And I think despite her stated intent to just siphon views from
him, I do think she gave a substantive transformational criticism
uh or sorry commentary that was like that was purposeful. That
wasn't like her just watching trying to steal money as much as
possible. That did become that wasn't a market replacement. That
was basically like taking somebody's political opinions and their
their criticisms of somebody they've participated in a back and
forth with and they engage in that same back and forth. And nobody
who watched or very few people if any who watch Denims would
have liked to watch that through Ethan Klein's POV or only with
Ethan Klein. I think they would have waited and watched it with
Assan. They would have waited and watched it with like some other
content creator they wanted to watch it with. I think that's
broadly where my head's at. So yeah, I don't I don't think I'd
be down with this Denim's lawsuit in any case.
I think I think that is going to chill critical reaction content
if it goes through to a trial. he was going demon mode and framing
this as a spite suit. Sure, I I get where you're coming from.
Like, yeah, if he was just being honest about his emotions and
stuff, but I I really don't think I like I think it's bad in
general to set that precedent. And I hope that I hope there's
some way, but unfortunately with the stream thing, I think Denims
might get, but I hope with the other one that that there's a
chance she doesn't. Yeah, I hope with the with the content, nuke,
the actual content, no evidence that the kind of president that
would be uh produced by this lawsuit, and he knows this, would
be limited to this non-element, which is the intentional siphoning
rationale. I think it's so bizarre, so beyond the pale, it's
not what's going on. And he couldn't have known in advance when
he was making this plan that these kinds of incriminating statements,
these admissions were going to be made. He couldn't have known
that. And I think that the evidence suggests that um he was planning
to sue people initially. He was set in a trap, but it wasn't
a trap for this kind of specific subset of infringement. Um it
was a trap for people who infringe who he didn't like. That's
what he was trying to do. But okay, so you are calling him disingenuous
here. You're basically saying that he's lying. But but like kind
of to me there's like a couple things that I look at where it's
entirely plausible that Ethan is being genuine with this, which
is the fact that number one, there was a history of people doing
this very specific thing that passes this other threshold of
like going into actual malice. Like there was a history of this
happening. It was targeted at Ethan, particularly with the Snark
community. Here's what I think is the most likely situation.
Like I think he was going after the snark the snark subreddit
before he thought about going after the creators and no nope
no he was thinking about Hassan Hassan's orbit. That's 100% what
he was thinking about when he registered that copyright. It was
after the fact when like maybe he didn't really maybe he didn't
expect that the creators themselves would just come out and say
let's take a view from Ethan. But I do think Hutch is just totally
incorrect. Like he he's already uh targeted uh people and he
literally said he literally talked about it. I mean, I guess
Hutch is Hutch is doing some mind reading now in the opposite
direction. He's doing some mind reading of Ethan and saying when
Ethan says that he was thinking about these creators and how
they would react to it and how he could sue these creators specifically,
he was lying within the Snark subreddit.
The Snarkers aren't copying that. So, no, no, but they you're
not listening. like the snark subreddit for for the leftovers
H3 or whatever that subreddit has been over the last year regularly
posting uh so like any kind of content for him. They go out of
their way to take views from him. He already he's already targeting
somebody in the Snark subreddit with a lawsuit from like two
or three months ago because this person posted a a post in the
Snark that was like an alternative post so that it didn't give
Ethan a view and then Ethan issued a DMCA and the person who
did this post counter claimed the DMCA which is a huge that's
like textbook DMCA. If you're doing fraudulent counter claims
that's like a textbook DMCA situation. Wait, counter What do
you mean he counter claimed it? Does he mean like he um does
he just mean that Wait, why would it be fraudulent? I'm pretty
sure if you want a counter claim, you literally have to say if
you want to basically somebody claims your content, uh if if
somebody claims your content is as theirs, then you can you can
literally say, "No, no, no. I'm going to fight this." And if
you do that, you have to give away your doc's information to
let them sue you because you're saying we'll go to court outside
of like YouTube or whatever, right? Right there. So, he already
has this history. Oh, sorry. outside of Reddit I guess in this
case like going after the snark for this like very thing that
he's going after these creators for and then on top of that he
has an established it's belied by his own words he says that
he not that he was going after the he was going after the reactors
he says very clearly I want to make the most delicious piece
of content but he said specifically that it's in the video himself
but he said in the video I couldn't have possibly dreamed that
the creators would be stupid enough to just come out and say
I'm going to take your content wait a second to me oh yeah
wait how does Hutch know that but Hutch has been arguing ing
that he knew that they would say those things. Oh, Pisco forgot
about that. I forgot about that. And now Pisco just realized,
wait, how do you how do you know about that? Well, you've been
arguing the opposite of that for 30 minutes that you couldn't
possibly that you think that he totally knew that they would
actually do that and that they had done it before and you clipped
of them doing it before. You totally lied about that, by the
way. And now you're saying, "Oh, he did himself." So now Hudge
is in another case where he's going to have to say, "Well, but
I think he could have thought that even though he said he didn't
for the content." Okay, maybe it's just for the content. He's
actually lying in the video again. Wait a second. So, so I actually
forgot about that. Wait, I So, when he say he couldn't have dreamed
that they were going to do this, right, that's that's brother
Hutch is like
he's actually putting in a Tom Fooleryesque performance right
now. This is amazing. I couldn't have expected them to make these
admissions, right? If he's
But you're not listening. But you're not listening, though. I'm
saying I think it's more plausible that his initial goal was
to trap the snark subreddit and then these specifically the snark
subreddit who h he has an intense beef with these people. Can
we just watch uh I'm suing suing these three creators piece of
content. Oh, it's right here. That I knew that these streamers
couldn't resist. They couldn't avoid the temptation of watching
it the second it was published. I don't we literally we don't
have to talk about the snark subreddit. We don't even have to
pretend. We don't have to pretend at
We didn't have to pretend. We don't have to pretend. We know
for a fact he was going out to the streamers. This idea that
he's going after Stark is it's so
because they're filled with some of the most psychotic parasocial
individuals you could possibly imagine that obsessed about him
and his wife that celebrated the CPS stuff that regularly do
this malicious like theft of his content. I think it's way more
plausible that he was specifically targeting them and then people
like Denims were stupid enough to come out and say, "I'm let's
steal the thing." And so he's like, "Fuck it. Let's throw them
on the back. No, no, no, no. He He He registered his work, right?
He He think, For some reason, Hutch has like written this in
his head that Ethan Klein is really It's all about malicious
stealing. That's all this has ever been about. No, it's not what
it's about. It wasn't even remotely what it was about. He was
trying to get these people on reactions. He said as much. He
registered it to get them to get these streamers, quote unquote.
These streamers,
right? He's just buying some post hawk Coke that Ethan's fed
him. I have no idea why he's just why he's just letting Ethan
shovel this [__] down. You don't believe in Ethan's
character, Jason? Uh, no I don't. He registered his work to sue
a reactor, right? He wanted to sue a reactor. Agreed. We should
We should I think he wanted to sue the snark. That's what I'm
saying.
You would need to Oh, did Pisco not have Did Pisco not have the
clip? Did he not have the clip, bro? Did he not have the clip
have underlying copyright to see the snark? Like, for example,
in the clip example, dude, how the did I have this? This was
like literally just where I I don't even have a time stamp in
my URL. Like I just have like the regular URL. I didn't have
a time stamp. This is like where I stopped watching. It was right
there perfectly for the exact context I needed for the stream.
I am like God's favored favored content creator. Okay. The the
YouTube video knew exactly where I needed it to be and it just
popped up there perfectly. But you said I'm assuming the Snark
guys are copying, right? So they're hosting the they're hosting
the clip somewhere and they're putting it on a server somewhere
and so they're infringing on his copyright. Um, so yeah, if you
wanted to go after the Snark people, but the Snark people aren't
putting their faces out to react to stuff. Yeah, you can. Maybe
he was intending to go after the Snark people as well to the
extent that they were copyrighting or sorry, they were violating
his I think he was specifically targeting them. I think he did
not think that other creators would be so dumb to do what Denims
did. This is the most cope argument I've ever heard of my entire
life. Ethan, you literally just have to go. Ethan was blatantly
lying about all of his reasoning for registering this. All of
his reasoning for Yeah. Everything. He He's just lying. nothing
Ethan said in the first like 10 minutes of his video is true.
That's a bold position from Hutch that I don't think Hutch would
actually own. So I if he if you think that he could not have
um thought that people like Denims were going to would make admissions
then it it's clear that his strategy at the start of it wasn't
which was to go after reactors, right? He says he says I want
to make a piece that's so that they have to react to it, right?
That we should actually get the uh I'm going to watch I'm going
to watch uh just the first two minutes on two times speech. Give
me Can you just give me Can we put a pause just for two minutes?
Is Pisco going to get to it? I think Pisco might get to it. He
might get to it. Hi there. My name is Ethan and my favorite hobby
is spending hundreds of thousands of dollars on the four minutes.
Oh, he's going to miss it if he only watches two minutes. Most
egregiously, it would reload the entire He calls it egregious
by he calls what Hassan and XC do. They he calls it egregious.
No, the same title so that they can traffic from the original
video.
I don't mind people reacting to my videos, but I do mind when
they play the entirety of my video. But honestly, what's wrong
with just over those people or is doing it specifically to [__]
on them? Uh that you are doing it on a video that yes, it's that
is of a critic that is so you're suing them. It's of a critic
and they are doing a substantial reaction and you're suing them
for that, right? You're doing something that basically
uh I would say like 50 to 80%
I'm not even going to say that. Let's say like 95% of commentary
streamers do, right? And there are a lot of them. This is like
something 95% of commentary streamers do. You would be chilling
all of that in any any of the critical people doing that by doing
this. And he has explicitly said he doesn't want to do that.
Right? So it's it's quite bad that you would that you would do
this while saying you don't want this. Right? He is explicitly
doing something. Now if he is just like all of you guys, I hate
react content. I think all React content is immoral and I'm going
to sue this person who's as bad as it can be where it's like
a gray area like where I'm pretty sure I could win and I want
to sue this person but then but then if he wanted to do that
just go after XQC. XQC is significantly worse. Talk about the
three denims. I'm just talking about Denims. Denims is the counter
example for why he's not getting what he wanted to do done right.
Why he is actually risking people like a bunch of his peers in
a way that he is lying about. If he had just gone after Caseyron
and Frogan, maybe I don't care as much. Maybe, well, maybe I
don't have the same criticisms, but it's the fact I I'd have
to watch more Frogan stuff. I'd have to actually go watch like
the Froggen YouTube reaction. I also find it interesting
that
I believe who is the person, was it me, who brought up the the
XQC thumbnail and the Frogan thumbnail? I think Straighter sent
those to me. And I wonder, has he DMCA anything on YouTube at
all? Why hasn't he DMCA any of those creators? Like if he makes
no effort to use the DMCA system as it exists for like far worse
infringers,
would that not also show that this is just I don't know. But
XQC can afford to good lawyers can afford to eat the costs. And
so so you think he's just bullying them? Yeah, I think that's
gay. I think it's gay to risk like an entire section of your
peers like who who do this like reaction content, this like long
form commentary.
I think it's really gross to risk your peers and everything they
do because you don't like these guys and you want to bully them
and you think they'll fold first. I think that's super gross.
Um, and you risk like basically chilling all critical commentary
at least all critical commentary that uses the full source. You
risk all of it because you don't like these people. Yeah, I I
just don't think so. I think it's gay. A face in the corner of
the occasional disruption does nothing to address that issue.
My video is being played from the beginning to end someone else's
stream video. It's neither nor necessary to feature the entire
someone else's work. doing a hate watch that isn't it transformative
is really dumb. Yes, but that's not what happened with denims.
We don't think they're minimum
reaction every but question no I don't think understandably this
may be angry because why should these content thiefs essentially
get more views he calls what xc does thievery content thieves
why should they get views he calls it thievery just like I don't
like in justice he says that one
debate I'm sad to report that I was terribly owned so in that
regard at all about hang on I'm going to step away literally
yeah go for it does that matter that might be illegal does that
matter to you what if it's watching
okay sure I mean that the ultimate debate, bro. He went with
the worm. Oh, and I think that burst. I can ask you, but he is
not the one I'm suing. Despite my criticism, he's not a relationship
in the suing, you'll see are much, much worse. He's getting there.
He's getting there. He'll get close. After this debate and in
the wake of this large conversation, the problem seems to have
only gotten worse. You have people like Son Periper paving the
uh DB87, it probably doesn't have to go to court because most
of the people who engage in this stuff don't actually want to
take it to court. Uh people people just don't it's like not worth
it, right? It's just not worth it because the actual damages
here for most of these cases, most people don't intentionally
register to do this kind of like uh this kind of uh lawsuit trolling,
most people don't register the Library of Congress to do this,
right? So, so you could only if you're not registered with the
Library of Congress, you can only be awarded actual damages.
The actual damages, even from the Denim's case, are probably
nowhere near worth it in terms of like the actual lawyer's fees
you'd have to pay, right? So, nobody bothers. It's all such small
small fry, nobody cares. It's not a big deal. That's why it's
like unanswered.
It doesn't eventually have to go to court because nobody's actually
suffering enough damage to really take it to court. Fair use
of what's known as cherry reacts when someone gets up to go to the
bathroom or to eat. And and now just for the for the people he's
talking about Hassan's chair reacts, his chair reacts where not
when Assan is giving them malicious intent, right? So this is
again he's saying it's gotten even worse. It's gotten even worse.
And how's it gotten worse, Ethan Klein? Well, the chair reacts,
but that's not malicious intent. That's not saying micious intent.
So the way in which it's getting worse isn't malicious intent.
So he's clearly identifying um the kind of non-ransformative
as what's being egregious. Okay. So continuing on whatever disappears
for extended period of time for his chair, Mr. Chair they call
it. You have to warn people to delete the area.
Right. He's identifying the the chair reacting even though Yeah.
XQC does the exact same thing. Exact same thing. So in no way
is it more to cost to register it. Is it like 200 bucks 250 bucks?
Might even be like 50 or 100. It's not it's not more than like
250 reg. Yep. Yep. Yep. Yep. And it was in the setting that I
formulated an idea. What if I could make I formulated an idea.
I formulated idea. What if I could make a long form content that
I knew that these streamers couldn't resist? That I knew that
these streamers couldn't resist. Yes, thank you. He finally got
there. He finally got there. So again, I can't wait to see how
Cut Hutch how Hutch copes his way through this. How will he cope
the temptation of working of watching it? The second it was published.
The second it was these people to steal my video is that I knew
they would. I knew they would. I knew that they would steal my
video. I knew that they would steal my video. Okay, your video.
I had little to no commentary. React to it instantly, giving
them no time to form an opinion. The trap was set and it worked
even better than I imagined it would. We capt every large stream
reacting to it entirely immediately. Oh my god. Oh, this is so
bad. This is so bad for Heathan. Hang on. I'm so glad that Thank
you for making me watch this. Hang on. It's an actual Tom Fury
moment. Like unironically was a total Tom Fury moment.
And is Pisco going to do I think Pisco likes Hutch. So I hope
Pisco doesn't rub it in. The problem if you if you guys remember
when we watched the Tom Fury Pisco debate, Pisco rubbed in that
Tom was like so bad at debating that he like actually convinced
Pisco of things he hadn't considered before. like that went against
Tom's position and he does this like I think almost unconsciously
like Pisco
you notice this with a lot of people who have like a pedigree
of sorts who come from like a either wealthy background or like
a highly educated background who work very hard to get to where
they are they will sometimes be like or put people down in a
way that like is almost almost like breathing for them like it's
really not conscious and I think I've noticed that with Pisco
a decent amount. I don't think he's a bad person. I don't think
he's a bad person at all, but he does it. Okay. And so I'm hoping
he won't do it to Hutch, who is like a co-odcaster
of his does the same like the uh what the Live and Learn podcast
with him. I hope not. But I feel like he almost can't help it
sometimes when somebody doesn't know what they're talking about
and he's like talking to them. So I'm I'm excited to see cuz
he's Thank you for making me watch this. That's not quite over
the line, but if he goes any further than that, it's going to
be immediately. Oh my god. Oh, this is so bad. This is so bad
for Heathan. Hang on. I'm so glad. Thank you for making me watch
this. Hang on. Instantly, giving them no time to form union.
The tribe was even better than I imagined it would. We captured
pretty much every large stream reacting to it in its entirety
immediately after it was published. Now, the thing is there were
a few people that went above and beyond to commit infringment.
For example, sit here silently with nearly Oh, so Ethan just
doesn't know that it's above
um it isn't earned. Yes, it is an earned. It is it is it's not
even that it's an earned. It's like a that comes from working
harder than people so much of the time and then having to watch
them like try to say that they ear they are owed as much as you
that that's like I've known a couple people like like Pisco that
I think work like 20 hours a day and and when they get into an
argument with somebody who they perceive as lazy, they will like
lose their mind at the idea that like your ideas are worth as
much as mine. No, they're not. You didn't work anywhere near
as hard. Shut the up. do not compare yourself to me is like the
energy they give off, right? So, it's like not even really about
it being earned. It's like uh it's like anger at other people's
lack of concern or care or considerateness, right? Like like
the idea that you speak to me and waste my time when you don't
put any time into learning whether or not your opinion is correct
offends me. You is like the energy I get sometimes from Pisco.
Oh my god. Okay. 50,000 live viewers. That's 30 times her regular
viewership. She's working directly with the smart subreddit moderators
to siphon views and their intentions couldn't be clear. Here's
an excerpt from a sticky post from the dark subreddit. Hey everyone,
we've seen a lot of comments about wanting to watch a new without
showing some support for H3. Here's a list of viewers who supported
our sub either by engaging with us directly or citing our post
in their critique of H3. Here are offering these streamers as
market substitutes for more. This is Cardinal send a copyright
infringement. The snark subre has been a frequent and persistent
infringing finger. That's why I knew when this video came out
the snarkers were going to encourage, promote, and push streamers
to commit copyright infringement. I should thank the snarkers
actually because of their predictability. They acted like double
agents for us incriminating their favorite streamers and serving
them up on a golden platter. So, thank you Snark. It's one thing
for a subre to admit it's engaging copyright, but how do you
get the streamers themselves to admit that they're stealing content?
Well, guys, uh if you enjoyed um not giving any views to that
terrible video, follow, subscribe, throw a prime if you like
the content. and you enjoyed your time here. It turns out they
just do it for you. You couldn't cook up a more incriminating
statement if you tried. Venom's the queen of self owning. You
prevail again. There's one thing about copyright you should know
is that he got registered before to be eligible for statuto damages
and attorney which is biting. He literally he literally suggest
Yes. He literally says that was his whole point and says that
he was trying specifically to go after the uh Rob. Lots of people
will give that vibe until they realize that it like actually
pushes people away from them. And then for most people, they'll
realize like, "Oh, I actually like other people. I like being
social. I'm gonna try to control that." For a certain small subset
of people, it doesn't bother them at all. They're totally fine
with it. Yeah. Queen's probably one of those people, these streamers.
So, that's number one. Okay. So, so it's not just it's not just
going after the snark. He set the trap specifically for the streamers.
And he he says, "Hang.
I don't have an issue with it." that he knew what he knew would
by the time Queen turns 21 he'll be better I'm sure or at least
by the time he turns 27
yeah I think so happened by the time he turns 40 would steal
his video without
uh putting much commentary on it uh when there was instantly
no time to give an opinion and it worked even better than I imagined
it would. We captured pretty much every large streamer reacting
to it in its entirety immediately after it was published. So
it would work better even than he imagined it would. So he wasn't
planning, right? He he his plan was to capture large streamers
who played the video in its entirety without transforming it.
His plan wasn't to capture these admissions. And he was specifically
going after these individuals.
Um, not because of the admissions, but I think if I had to give
Ethan some sort of charity here, here's what's possible. He could
have wanted to do this, wanted to sue big streamers who reacted,
people, even just his enemies who reacted to this in any way
and like go after them in court and then somebody might have
talked him out of it because of the potential chilling effect,
right?
So people people could have been he could have been talked out
of it like, "Hey, this will chill people. Hey, this will turn
the public against you. Don't do this. Don't do this." Right.
And then once he like had come up with the narrative, the CPS
happened, the skulls happened, okay, and he got like quite like
he got puffed up a lot, then it's possible went, you know what?
I'm going to go back and figure out how I can actually sue these
people. And then they were like, yeah, these three, they were
actually malicious. They said they wanted to take views from
me. That's what we'll go with. That's possible. Because of what
he said at the start of the video, which is what XQC starts to
do, not because of the malicious and ad, you know, admissions.
And so I totally disagree that we can but I I think this is all
like downstream of him wanting to go after these people. And
I think realistically the malicious thing might be kind of bad.
But again, the thing that shows him is totally disingenuous is
including the Denim's reaction to the content nuke in there.
Say that his plan at the start was to get these admissions. His
plan at the start was to make a piece of content so delectable
that it would attract streamers to watch it in its entirety and
to not give much commentary on it. And so it's unfortunate.
Okay. I thought Tyco was a total idiot for saying that Pisco
lost this debate. But if I listen closely here, I do believe
I detect a voice crack, which does mean it's over. He lost. It's
over streamers to watch it in its entirety and Oh. Oh, brutal.
Oh, oh, no. Oh, no. Pisk and to not give much commentary on it.
And so his plan was to go after such people and that the admissions
part is totally posth hawk. He was planning to sue regardless
of whether or not the specific admissions were made. Yeah, but
that's not incompatible what with what I've said. I've said my
whole thing the whole time. It is incompatible. He literally
were just arguing he wasn't caring about the streamers were going
after start. What the what the is what you're saying? I'm I mean
maybe it's incompatible with me theorizing that he was specifically
targeting Snark because it does sound like it's been a minute
since I watched that video that he had plans for specific creators.
Yeah. But that doesn't but that doesn't mean that it can't be
both of these things. Like you can you can have a plan to with
uh individual creators
um in their communities for for for things like having CPS called
on his house and then cracking jokes about it. I I told her I
told her that. Wait, I told her. And then at the same time, And
then at the same time, like you're confronted with, okay, so
now we have the material that we need. What do we want to do
from now on? Or like how how do what do we want to go? Where
do we want to go from here? And then it's to me it's totally
conceivable that he would think like, okay, well, if I if I sue
people like Asmin Golden and um and so again, this is going to
go. So, you're saying Ethan is lying here in terms of like what
he decided when he says it was like only about the streamers,
right? You're saying he's lying and then Hush is going to go,
"Well, I can't possibly say XQC." Then this this would lead to
like a lot of people just not doing React content. I don't want
to do that. So, let's like narrow it no to a more specific sub.
Wait a second. Wait a second. So, so I agree with the the first
part of what you said with respect that he was he had his targets
planned out and that it the CPS thing probably played a role
in it. And I I even think that that's a justifiable way to distinguish
it. But but let's just be 100 trillion% clear here. What he was
planning and planning for and expecting was for the streamers
that he was going to go after for them to do the whole video,
do it very close in time to when it was dropped and to not offer
much transformative nature in their content to just basically
watch it the whole thing. Yep. That to me suggests, and I hope
you would agree, that if that is to say, if they had not made
those admissions,
what his
his expectation was, I'm not getting those admissions. I'm suing
them anyway. [__] these people. I'm suing them. Were
would have been fulfilled. That is to say, the expectation he
planned for was that they would infringe his content. And regardless
of those admissions, they infringed on his content. And so the
plan was to sue for infringement regardless of admissions. Right.
Yes. Right. So then this whole thing about well we're only suing
after uh because of the specific malicious infringement intentional
siphoning that's all he acknowledges and knows that even without
the intentional siphoning rationale this is toxic. He in the
start of his video talks about how Hassan the chair reacts are
really really bad. Um I and XUC does that kind of too and that
doesn't include language to about intentional siphoning. Um and
he even starts by saying what Hassan and Xuc do does in general
is horrible and injustice theft. He says it's egregious. So there
is no world in which his original plan was to solicit damning
admissions to set a line to protect from Disney and Sony because
we really want to Yeah. the entire first like 5 10 minutes of
the video does doesn't make any sense. 5 minutes 5 minutes probably
you know punish infringement but just one type of infringement
the ones involving malice which is not an element to any of the
causes of action. Okay. You're trying to pro prove guilt beyond
a reasonable doubt. Right. So we got this we got a jury here.
Is it possible? Is it possible liability that Ethan had this
original plan
to use this trap to go after specific creators that he had personal
grievance with? And then once he was
presented with
their reactions, like what they did, he decided
that he would be more narrow in his targeting
because he came to the conclusion that if he would have gone
after XC and Asthma, it would have caused a lot of people to
just stop reacting, which was not his intent. Like, is that possible?
So if then what you're saying is going after XQC, the reason
he's not going after them is because it'll have more of a
um chilling effect. Chilling effect, which it would though. Why?
Which it would. Why do Hold on. You don't Yes. Why? Yes. Why?
Somebody has a far more substantive reaction. He's still going
after them. The malice you've admitted is not an element of the
cause of action.
So it doesn't matter to the court, right? He has a far stronger
case against XQC.
Why is he not going after XQC and going after Denims if any of
his stated goals are correct? Don't need this explained. No,
I I know why it's less. Why do people do this or to But you don't
need to explain this. Why do people do this? Like it doesn't
look good. No, it doesn't. I don't know. I have no idea. To not
go after XC, but
uh the reason isn't what you isn't what you're saying it is.
the reason it would be less chilling to go after denims and the
next or hey the first we're talking about his his motives and
who he's targeting given his stated uh goals right he doesn't
want to chill certain kinds of reactions Hutch is saying well
if he went after XQC that would do more to chill standard reactive
commentary standard reaction commentary than going after denims
that is factually incorrect that is factually
he is absolutely doing more to chill the exact thing he says
he wants to protect by going after denims than he would if he
went after XQC.
So he doesn't care about protecting things. He doesn't care about
protecting any of this. Does not give a and that is the point
is he is lying about giving a about that. Does not care. XQC
is because everyone knows what his real intent is
they know that no that if you give positive coverage you're not
at risk. That's what people know that the reason why going after
XQC would be positive coverage. You think that's what this is?
Yes. 100%. You think Okay, hold on. So now I feel like we're
at a different conclusion here. Now you seem to be saying that
not only is the idea that he is trying to protect or or improve
and protect and and thereby protect the React community. Not
only is that his real intention is simply just to like silence
anyone who critic critiques him. No, no. I I think that infringement
is a but is a necessary condition. So in order to go after people
to silence them um or or to start to go after people in general
that infringement is a but for necessary condition but there's
another necessary condition which is he needs to have a vendetta
or not like you in some way and one of the reason one of the
ways in which you cannot like you is if you have negative coverage
but if you for example even yeah so here's here's example but
it goes beyond negative coverage though we're so beyond negative
coverage when we're talking about CPS calls. No, I agree. I'm
not disputing the notion that the individuals he targeted, he
could have some legitimate basis to target. We just get to I
don't understand why everybody here just supports this idea that
like you can treat all these people like like I can treat Caseyron
and Frogan and Denims as if they all called CPS. Yeah. Why why
do you support this idea this like this uh collective guilt element?
Okay. It seems like a lot of these people who are on the pro-
Zionist side, they they support collective punishment in like
all cases. It's like a principled position they have. It's like
some person from your community might have called CPS on me,
so I'm just going to take all your money. But it's not like he
doesn't even Yeah, he doesn't even But he doesn't narrow it down
to any one of the communities either. Yes. It's insane them based
on things. I want to make it clear and correct the record. I
did not think did not state do not did do not believe that Denim's
called CPS. Obviously, moronic, idiotic, stupid Ethan. Oh, well,
that's fun. I'm so glad that that quote exists. So, Ethan does
not think that Denims herself called CPS. Cool. Neat. Cuz it
happened before. I am not disputing that. I'm not saying at any
point that that is not a potential even justifiable reason to
go after some people and not others. I don't know how many times
I need to stress that. All I am saying is that I think Pisco
would say if he wants to go after these people and the the unfortunate
like issue there, right? This is totally fine. If Ethan just
says I will accept any downsides for going after these people
because these people I think they contributed to an environment
where my kids got CPS called or I got CPS called in my family.
They contributed to an environment where I got death threats
in the form of skulls. I don't care who it affects or how it
affects them. these people. If he said that like I'm I'll put
every rack streamer out of a job. I don't give a [__]
Then there isn't something to criticize in the same way, right?
I mean, I would still criticize him because I think you're being
this. I think you you totally participated in this entire reaction
thing the whole time. You're totally fine with people doing this
with your video before. I think it's totally
but like then we wouldn't have this like obvious hypocrisy, this
obvious lie from you, this obvious deception you're trying to
do to avoid the criticism. he would get the criticism he deserves
if he said that. But he won't say that. He's not saying it and
he should. That rationale is understandable. The rationale that's
not understandable is well, I was planning all along to enforce
this standard which isn't present in the copyright statute um
to you know have some level of judicial precedent but the judicial
president that isn't an all chilling of the broader reaction
community. And I don't want to chill XQC
and people like him. Even though I say that they're pervading
an injustice and they're egregious and what they're doing is
theft. I don't want to chill that. I want to protect. Are you
normally streaming at this time these days? No. Um, no. No, no,
no. I I happen to be like staying up late, so I figured I just
stream. I kind of wanted to watch the to the end of this, but
I don't know if it goes all the way to like the very end of the
VOD. I probably will have to cut it. I don't know. We'll see.
We could maybe make that. to me doesn't make any sense. Even
though he's previously said that that kind of is egregious and
wrong and he couldn't have planned in advance for the distinction
line that he's now pushing for those admissions to have come.
He couldn't have known that when he was setting up this whole
scenario when he was registering the copyright of the copyright
office when he was preparing for litigation that they were going
to have this dam damned admissions. In fact, he says I couldn't
have imagined right that it would be as good as it was. He wasn't
expecting them to say such obviously bad things. And so it can't
have been his design initially to just go after them for admissions
that he didn't perceive were going to happen. Yeah. I think what
I think what I'm saying is you can set out on some action or
whatever with a certain set of expect expectations or intentions
and then your thinking about what to do moving forward can change
in the moment based on other other considerations.
Supreme calls in after Hutch. Oh,
okay. Maybe we watch that tomorrow. I don't know if I could I
don't know if I can do it. I'm I'm pretty tired. So, okay, you're
Ethan, but what is the consideration? You're Ethan. You've set
you You're Ethan. You've set these traps. You have this personal
vendetta against these creators for CPS stuff and a bunch of
other stuff and then, you know, they
everybody else reacts and and then you have these creators that
I feel like people in my Discord might have gassed Supreme up
on this a lot. We'll see. We'll see how it goes. A whole another
level. You can. It's to me it's conceivable that Ethan would
be like, "Okay, well, what do I do from here and like maybe he
thought about maybe he thought about maybe he thought about Supreme's
a much better arguer than Hutch is." Uh, even arguing. Yeah.
I don't know what this is. I think even if Supreme has like an
opinion that's more difficult to defend, which I think he does,
he's basically going to argue that no, Ethan absolutely is trying
to protect from copyright infringement here, right? And even
though that I I think that's far more difficult. Like I didn't
know the part about it being a strict liability crime when I
talked to Supreme before. Like Pisco having that information
and knowing how to roll that into an argument I think totally
defeats his previous arguments. So we'll see. But I think when
Supreme knows he's wrong on something where he gets like information
to show he's wrong, he'll back down unlike Hutch and Tom Foolery
about um suing like a larger swath of creators. And then maybe
he came to a conclusion of like, well, wait, hang on a second.
I don't want to necessarily cause some kind of chain reaction
that's going to completely like stifle or or dis discontinue
altogether react content. Therefore, I'm going to try to do this
other thing. Like that's conceivable to me. I don't know Ethan's
thinking. You could be right, but that's conceivable. It's conceivable
to you that ex that Ethan could say that what XC is that another
mind read? Is that another mind read totally against what Ethan
stated in the video? Wow. he does is theft, but saying that preventing
XQC from committing theft that that has such bad secondary effects
that I wouldn't want to punish XQC
for you wouldn't want to punish the the React community for by
going after XQC.
Yeah. Yes, that's what I'm saying. Yes. Oh my god. I I I think
that that is I I think for example if some rights holder let's
say that if XQC started reacting to if this were true if this
were true at all he wouldn't have sued Denims right if that were
a concern that he is going to cause a chilling effect by suing
XQC he wouldn't be suing Denims that's just open and shut that's
like the easiest argument in the world very easy very simple
not hard to follow okay 4 hours versus two and a half hours okay
XQC ads I think like 40 minutes Denim's ads. She doubles the
run time or more, right? Denims actually like pulls videos, pulls
clips, tries to like pull context to like explain some things
Han's talking about. Actually makes political points. Uh XQC
says, "Uh, I'm not reacting. I'm just watching. It's like not
close." The Little Mermaid and Disney suit him. I think that
and all XQC did was like, "Yeah, bro. That crazy. Yeah, bro.
Crazy. Whatever. Yeah, crazy." And he just did a Little Mermaid
react and Disney suit him. I think ex that Ethan would say, "Yeah,
Brown, find out." I think Ethan would say, "Yeah, they're well
within their rights." Yeah, what XC did was wrong and I'm okay
with Disney suing to enforce their copyright. You don't think
he would say that? Denim screwed herself. It's so long nobody's
willing to watch. I just can't imagine watching it on stream.
It's like so It's like, dude, I Yeah, I I didn't want to watch
the original content, Duke. I didn't watch it. I've never watched
it. I've literally never watched that piece
boring. Boring. boring.
Um,
so yeah, the idea that I want to watch Denim's review it is just
crazy. Well, I mean, it's just pure speculation. I have no idea.
I mean, I I think it's to, like I said, I think it's totally
conceivable that Why is Hutch Why is Hutch comfortable speculating
that Ethan is lying about his motivations, but not comfortable
speculating in any of the directions Pisco suggests?
He's like, if I can speculate to defend Ethan, that's okay. If
I have to speculate, um, if I if I can say I couldn't possibly
speculate to defend Ethan, then that's good, too, right? Like,
if there's anything but rock solid proof, I'm going to say I
couldn't possibly speculate, but if I could defend Ethan by speculating,
I'm just going to speculate without actually maintaining the
same bar at all. That he could talk about on his podcast where
it's like, I think what XQC was did was wrong, but I could see
this I could see this causing a chilling effect. Like, that to
me is not out of the realm. You don't you don't seem to entertain
that. I I think that that is such an implausible
uh possibility that what he's he's saying is what's really important
because he is trying to assert a standard right so he is saying
I am trying to chill some stuff right it wouldn't make sense
that he's painting himself as protecting the reaction community
if he weren't trying to set at least some kind of standard right
so if he's trying to set some kind of standard right agreed right
he's trying to set a standard an internal standard for the insiders
to adhere to fair all he has to do to prove this is drop his
lawsuit against denims entirely
right if he's actually scared about chilling uh chilling criticism
and chilling people who do transformative reactions. All you
got to do is drop the lawsuit against denims or drop the content
nuke part and only do the stream and litigate that out that you
feel like she ch reacted to your stream and you want to sue her
for that. I guess yes. And in doing so, would you acknowledge
that you can protect the community? Yeah. Jorge the first there's
no there's 0% chance that it only affects unhinged people like
Denim. That's that's not where the chilling effect is. Yeah.
you you actually don't understand like what can be set via precedent
or like what what like a court decision would actually take into
account. Not going to say, oh, you really don't like Ethan. Uh
so reactions from people who really don't like someone, those
are bad. Yeah, it's uh you like the React community that will
not be a part of it at all. Intent has nothing to do with this.
By imposing better standards, you could reduce the risk of something
bigger happening later down the line. I'm not saying that it's
uh in incomprehensible that you could protect the community by
imposing some kind of internal vote to acquit. No. Then you must
vote to No. But here what the the standard that he's proposing
which is I in order to protect from Disney and Sony the the standard
that that will protect that I think will protect from Disney
and Sony is the standard of stated intentional malice. You think
that that's what he's thinking? That what will protect us from
Disney and Sony is imposing a standard on the community of intentional
stated malice? That's really I think it's more just I think it's
more just the idea that he could he could he could um I think
part of the problem tell me you agree. I think part of the problem
was is that with the you want to go to go over Supreme call.
I bro I sorry but I I streamed for like two hours and then I
took like three hours off or four hours off and then I streamed
for five hours. I'm probably not I've been awake a long time.
Twitch lefty streamers specifically, there's been a sort of level
of impunity that has been going on for like a year and a half.
Level I don't know what that means. Level of impunity. Can you
tell me what you mean? Would you agree that there has been a
double standard in the enforcement of TOS and that it is very
likely that Yes, I agree. Okay, that's what I'm that's what I'm
talking about. Maybe not necessarily total impunity, but like
the fact in a way that harms Ethan Klein. No, not in a way that
harms even glad. Like the mere fact that people like fren uh
frenoms. Why? What is this relevant to? The double what would
the double standard on Twitch be relevant to with regards to
copyrighted content? We'll just call them frenoms. We'll combine
the names. What do you mean the chance to even the score? What
do you mean? Why? Why in the would he be I have no idea why he's
bringing it up. That's the score they got to settle. Does the
intent really not matter? Uh does it not contribute to the purpose
purpose of the use? No. strict liability crimes.
Strict liability crime, the the intent doesn't matter. You can
say, "I'm intending to create a market replacement. I want to
take views away from this person," and not take views away from
them, and it it literally would not count as market replacement,
right? You need to prove the reality of the market replacement
question. Um the the stated intent doesn't mean you're replacing
it. And there can be arguments made on both sides. It it does.
So the the actual malicious intent shows that it's willful infringement,
right? Like if if you do if you do deem it to be infringement,
then it would be willful infringement. They are willfully risking
it, right? Like they are reacting the thing in full. If you deemed
it infringement, it's not like you could argue against that.
Yeah. Sure. Yeah. So for I think Pisco seems to say that both
are strict liability for copyright infringement and for the elements
of uh fair use that that there isn't an intent element to any
of them. I think that's pretty clear. Now, oh, I'm trying to
think like nature of the work. Maybe possibly you could try to
read into one of those things, but I think with regards to federal
statutes, I think US District Courts with federal statutes read
them fairly textually and do not read things in like you're not
supposed to read things in to the law in terms of like lower
courts, federal statutes. But anyway,
that frenoms,
the mere fact that Frenhams just said this openly, I think indicates
a level of impunity. They didn't even entertain the possibility
that they would get in trouble for this. I And so I I I think
so because Twitch won't hold them accountable, Ethan has to hold
won't hold them accountable for and again, Denims did get banned
for reading the Osama bin Laden letter. No. So, like I guess
it's for what did Denims do that she didn't get banned for that
she should have gotten banned for by Twitch. I actually don't
know. I'm trying to think. There's got to be one of them, right?
I'm trying to think of like how this affected Ethan in some way.
But Hutch is basically arguing because of the double standard
for these content creators, they think they can do whatever they
want and so we have to teach them they can't do whatever they
want. Okay.
You have to risk the entire like React commentary community to
do it or so that's because I don't think that's responsive to
what I'm saying. So, I agree that he could feel very hard done.
I agree that there's a double standard at Twitch. I agree that
they're impermissibly, you know, being unfair and all that [__]
And I'm not disputing anything you're saying. I've said it in
the past. I'm saying, do you think it's conceivable that in Ethan's
mind when he was dividing his video or when he was deciding to
sue people, some people versus others, that in his mind was,
I'm going to set an internal standard that protects against Sony
and Disney. And that internal standard is stated intentional
malice. That's the kind of internal standard that will protect
us from Disney and Sony. Do you think that that was conceivably
going through his mind? No, I'm not. No, I'm not saying that
he originally set up without saying no. Even after even after
the reactions happened and when he was devising his strategy
on who to sue, this is after before his trap after his trap has
been sprung that after when he's decided how to do the litigation,
he thought to himself, hm, I really want to protect the content
community from people like Sony and Disney. And the way I'm going
to do that is I'm going to divine a standard, an internal compliance
standard, and that standard will be to protect us from Sony and
Disney, no stated intentional malice. And when we do that, it
will protect us from No, but I think I think it goes beyond that.
I I think he's not necessarily just trying to set a standard
where outright malice would be completely off the table. I think
he I think he's sort of just gen a standard you essentially cannot
set generally like or at the very least I should say I think
it's plausible to me that that no no that he wasn't necessarily
thinking in specifics of like okay I want to engineer a very
specific outcome where this specific standard is set in this
specific standard and this specific but just generally just to
like send send the message that like some actions can be taken
like that legal actions can be taken. Okay. But I mean this is
just this is just speculation, but I'm just saying like it's
possible he didn't have like No, no, but because Ethan is very
specific. He says that he wants to enforce this line. This line
being the malicious line that that's the line he wants to enforce.
And the reason he wants to enforce that is to protect Sony and
Disney. He can't be that naive, right? He could. I mean, first
of all, I don't know if it's naive, but second of all Oh, what's
up? How's it going? What's up? How's it going, man? You're right.
I was calling in about the um about the purpose and the intent.
Um,
especially cuz you seem to know a lot more about this than I
do. Okay. So, I'm not trying to argue that it's not, you know,
a strict liability offense cuz it's kind of, you know, you you
kind of do it. It doesn't mean whether you intended to copyright
infringe, right? But in terms of the purpose of the use, if Ethan
can successfully argue that no, the primary purpose why they
chose to include my content in their stream, their video, their
whatever isn't for the purpose of criticism, commentary, kind
of like, you know, some kind of engagement with the content.
If he can prove that their primary purpose is to infringe and
is to divert viewership, that's going to be an argument to the
effect on the original work. But is that also also not going
to be an argument to the purpose of the work being included not
being fair use? Uh I don't Can you show me where that is an element
of like why why it is included? The purpose and character of
the purpose and character the nature I I get it. So the nature
of the work right? So hold on let me pull up the fair. No no
the the first factor. Oh character use. Oh whether the use is
commercial or for nonprofit educational purposes. Oh, well, hold
on. I need to I need to go and find this and see like I need
to look further into the purpose part because if the purpose
is like nonprofit versus um can I see us fair factors purpose
and character let's see let's just like actually look at what
it is like a more
uh more full reading of it. First factors the purpose and the
character of the use whe including whether use is of a commercial
nature or is for nonprofit educational purposes. To justify the
use is fair, one must de demonstrate how it either advances knowledge
or the pro or the progress of the arts through the addition of
something new. Again, uh so for what I would say here is basically
do you think something would be fair use if you said uh my intention
is to teach people things with this and then you watch the whole
thing like front to back versus if you said my intention is to
steal this without adding anything and I want to make money off
of it and I want to take money away from them. So you say you
say that, but then you do a transformative reaction that is like
literally like almost like like there would be no reason for
somebody to watch your version versus the original version unless
they wanted your opinion. Like I think what you say and what
you state doesn't really have an effect on the actual uh like
purpose and character,
right? Would those not be all part of one holistic argument though
on to the purpose and the character of the use? Because let's
say that, you know, you've got kind of like a middling transformative.
Is it transformative? H you could kind of go either way on it.
If they say beforehand, yeah, it guys watch me. Don't watch Ethan.
Does that not then weigh on that
Uh I don't know how I don't know how it could like I guess technically
this is all going to a jury. So technically you could say, "Oh,
I want this included because it could, you know, sit in the jury's
mind." But I think I think it's something where the judge could
say you can't take it into account when you're considering this.
So we'd have to see. Uh let me see here. So is it is it is it
purely just like a media analysis? What is the purpose in this
work? Death of the author. It can't be that though, can it? If
you're soon for copyright infringement, there's no way.
I don't know what you mean by death to the author here. Oh, in
terms of like if you just look at the media and ignore the perhaps
like the purpose of the person creating the media, what is the
purpose of the inclusion? Well, you don't just look at the media,
you look at how the media is like um how it acts in like the
same markets and stuff too as well, right? Yeah. Yeah. But I'm
saying we completely the intention going into it. I actually
think you you more or less completely ignore the intention intention.
Sorry. Uh Pisco said as much. I've done my own like try like
trying to read on this. I've I've seen as much that it is a like
a strict liability crime that it is essentially not included
here. Now, in terms of purpose and character of the use, I mean,
I think the way it affects this is like there's clearly a like
the primary purpose is commercial, right? Like I think you do
get to the part where it's commercial and they probably lose
on this factor. So, you'd have to go to the other factors and
try to see like where where they might be able to win, right?
Yeah, but would that just Okay, because the thing that I've read
is that the purpose of the use isn't just for whether it's commercial
or non-commercial. It's also whether it's used for the purpose
of critique, commentary, something that's you're like adding
more information or you're adding like another slant or another
argument to it.
Sorry, you got to say that whole thing again. I was like reading
there. I again I that's why I was like I don't know if you want
to come on tonight. I am like actually exhausted but go ahead.
No, it's fine. It's it's not just a binary is it used for commercial
or is it used for like non-commercial. There's also an assessment
kind of holistically there of whether it's used for the purposes
of commentary, critique, you know, to kind of like further an
idea. There is there is like a deeper there is a deeper analysis
there in terms of are you just like selling this? Are you intending
to get money? And I think wouldn't that be a mountain substanti
uh no no sorry there's a transformative where is transformiveness
the it's uh one of these god why am I used how much is used
this market replacements
is this going to be god why can't I can't use my brain right
now that's sly fair I think the way that I do see people or the
the the places where I do see people bring up transformiveness
is in the first factor
because here's hold on um let's read this because the thing that
I'm guess I'm worry I I'm wondering is we've never you with no
other kind of media would you have it where you use a piece of
copyrighted work you intend to go in to use it in a certain way
and then in the end you actually don't right if you're making
a film if you're making a book you can say oh well when I when
I planned to write the book I did it this which not really cuz
the way that you went in and wrote it, your purpose of including
it was met out when you kind of like thought about it, prepared
it beforehand. Do you know what I mean?
Yeah. Can I hold on? Can I read this part? In determining that
Prince's appropriation art could constitute fair use and that
many of his works were transformative fair uses of Ky Kio's
Kyu's photographs, the second circuit in Kyu Brs
shed light on how transformative use is determined. What is critical
is how the working question appears to the reasonable observer,
not simply what an artist might say about a particular piece
or body of work. The district court's conclusion that Prince's
work was not transformative is partly based on Prince's deposition
testimony that he doesn't really have a message and that he was
not trying to create anything new uh with a new meaning or me
a new message. However, the artist's intended message is not
dispositive. Instead, the focus of transformative
use inquiry is how the artworks will be reasonably perceived.
So apparently it can go into it slightly in the first factor
in the transformativity. So if you say I am not intending to
transform this apparently that can but is not dispositive and
you do actually have to look at how it will be reasonably perceived.
So to me that means dude I'm so [__] close to becoming
a communist. Just get rid of all at this point. [__]
me. I like I am totally fine with people. It seems like so it
can weigh into this factor of fair use possibly,
but
this is them. So this is them saying it. This artist message
is not dispositive. 21. Let me see here. 21. Kyrie first prince
B. Oh wait, what? Can you Can you not? Can you not? Can you not?
Oh my god. Hold on. Yeah. Why? Why are you doing this? Oh, why
are you taking me back up? Oh, this is just the whole thing for
Kai verse prince, isn't it? Oh god. I can I No, there is nothing.
Nope, there is no link to this. So, you'd have to look into this
and see. I guess so. It sounds like he's saying I don't have
a message. I I intended I didn't intend to create anything new
here. H
I would say it probably was ruled against him partially because
of that. It says partially, but like I I think this is what I'd
have to do is see if this is like a copy like a straightup copy
with that is that like isn't different because I would say probably
at a base level there is some transformativity to just streaming
content with a community there and stuff. Now, do I think that's
anywhere near enough to get like to the po point where you like
um pass this test or or where you're not paying for this? No.
But there is almost certainly I wonder if this one is somebody
literally just like putting a photo somewhere else,
right?
Both of them. Oh, let's uh hold on. This is a wiki article. Kyro
v. Prince is a copyright case of the United States Court of Appeals
of the SEC for the second court on the question of whether artist
Richard Prince's appropriation art treatment of Patrick Kyu's
photographs was copyright infringement or fair use. The second
circuit held in 2013 that Prince's appropriation art could constitute
fair use and that a number of his works were transformative fair
uses of Kyro's photographs. The court demanded to the district
court uh for the SDNY for reconsider reconsideration of five
prince's works. The Supreme Court denied Kyrie's petition for
a writ of s Cioari
and the case settled in 2014.
So it sounds like Prince won. Did they just say it got remanded?
Happened after it got remanded. Five of Prince's works. The Supreme
Court denied Kyra's petition. Oh, it settled though. It looks
like the case settled. It's Well, it did settle. Yes. But I'm
sorry, it settled because it kept getting sent up to higher courts,
right? And they kept sending it back down. They kept remanding
it. Yeah. Yeah.
Kyu was criticized both by academics and other courts for giving
too much weight to transformative use in determining fair use.
In 2021, another second circuit appeal hearing Andy Warhol Foundation
for the Visual Arts v. Goldsmith on appeal decided that some
clarification is in order since the trial had read too much into
its decision that Andy Warhol's orange prints had sufficiently
transformed the photograph it was based on as to not be infringing.
Twear later, the US Supreme Court affirmed this decision.
so SDNY in 2011 held that Prince's works were infringing. At
that point, Kyrov Prince case had received significant attention
because the court ordered that Prince's unsold works, the Rosolei
catalogs be pounded and destroyed. The SDNY found that the works
were not transformative in part because Richard Prince did not
claim to be commenting upon the original works. Okay, so they
originally found that's interesting. Prince whose works. So,
so Prince did not Now, I wonder if that's like a claim at the
time because the other thing denims can just show up in court
and say, "Well, I said this, you know, I was this was a part
of a character. I was I was commenting, right? So, I wonder how
much her statement affects it if she says her underlying belief,
her underlying like goal was to comment on it and do a standard
reaction. You know what I'm saying? Yeah. Like, can her can her
She can very very easily argue that well, I was just saying that
since they had watched mine, it was unlikely that they watched
the other, but that will be true whether or not it's a market
a market equivalent, right? Or a market substitution. Yes. Yeah.
Uh, let me keep reading this just cuz I want to see where they
uh where they look. Prince, whose works often sell in galleries
for many thousands of dollars, appealed to the second court or
second circuit, sorry. The case was of high interest to the art
world, which largely favored Prince's position, and to the photographic
community, which largely favored Ku's position. In April 2013,
the second circuit reversed the lower court, finding that most
of Prince's works were indeed transformative to a reasonable
observer and therefore fair use. In particular, the circuit found
that the lower court aired in requiring that the appropriating
artist claimed to be commenting on the original work and found
works to be transformative if they presented a new aesthetic.
A secondary work may constitute fair use, even if it serves some
purpose other than those criticism, comment, news, reporting,
blah blah blah blah blah identified in the preamble to the statute,
wrote judge Bington Daniels Parker for the three judge panel.
Our conclusion should not be taken to suggest, however, that
any cosmetic changes to the photographs would necessarily constitute
fair use.
So these are examples of like the the
I mean he's lost it. Okay. I guess I guess I guess so. Fair use.
Let's go. Uh this photo worth nothing. This photo worth thousands
of dollars. Okay. God art communities are so cool. Uh the court
found 25 of the 30 works to be transformed to fair use under
its standard and remanded the case to the lower court for reconsideration
of five works five of the works under the second circuit's new
standard. In a separate opinion that concurred in part and desissented
in part, judge Jay Clifford Wallace of the 9th circuit sitting
in by designation said that while he agreed with the general
principles of transformative use the court had articulated. Having
done so, the court should have remanded all of Prince's images
to the district court for reconsideration under that standard
more in keeping with the general more in keeping with general
procedure. Wallace also differed over the exclusion of Prince's
statements as to his intent in creating his der derivative work
conceding that in Blanch the circuit had cautioned that such
statements were not uh cenaon
a conditional
oh I see not above we're not essential for use god I swear I
could read and figure this out on my own I'm just yeah I'm uh
we're at the end of the rope here he pointed out that it had
considered those statements in Castle talk Entertainment Inc.,
the Carol Publishing Group. Uh, in 2014, Carol and Prince, Kyu
and Prince settled the case before it was reheard in the district
court.
so that's so annoying. It's like a cold legal case where you
don't even get to see the like the final court ruling on it.
Yeah, but it seems like um it does seem like basically everybody
agreed that an intent statement is not conclusive in any way.
Oh man, I don't know if you've got this vibe. I don't know if
I'm going a little bit skitso here. So maybe you can maybe you
can give me a little bit of little bit of hopeium.
Uh I feel as though the more and more I kind of like try and
read into this like off stream, the more and more cuz I said
initially like the worst thing we can have for live streaming
is if the court is asked the question are live streams in general
like transformative use of copyrighted works? We don't want that
question asked. And I said the worst thing we could get realistically
is a huge new apparatus for like a test to analyze like live
streams to see if they are actually like transformative cuz you
are using the entire work. There is really very very little sense
to even go ahead and watch the the original if you've already
watched the reaction to it. Um, yeah. I mean, well, and I I think
the Denims case forces that question. Like, you can't get away
from that question by suing Denims for her content nuke reaction
where she goes from like an hour and 40 minutes or something
to 4 hours. Yeah, you can't get away from that question. But
the thing that I'm worried about is when I'm reading other kind
of like legal decisions or like existing precedent, I find it
really really hard to understand how any of it easily kind of
like fits onto any of the any any live stream reaction ever.
And so I feel as though we are going to come out the other side
of this in like probably two years with a whole new kind of like
I guess like a there's probably going to be some kind of test
or some kind of legal framework or some kind of like jurist prudence
specifically tailored to live stream reactions and that sounds
slightly terrifying. It changes the way that DMCA works. It changes
the way that DMCA appeals work if YouTube is then doing that
assessment on themselves. Is that likely or am I just a legal
layman going how could the can any of this fit and it'll be like
actually fine and this is like flexible enough that we won't
need an entire new kind of law to be able to assess it. I don't
know if you've got any cuz it seems like you've read more into
it than I have. I doubt I've read a lot more into it than you
have. It seems like under the like it seems like the current
fair use like the four pillars of fair use are it like yeah I
don't know how you start narrowing it down because it does seem
like way too broad to like yeah I think it's going to mostly
come down to using the whole like can you have something transformative
in video content that uses another work in its entirety right
and I don't know how you would get I don't know where you get
a line there that makes sense like a test that you could apply
that's going to be like easily applied such that you can like
solve most court cases before hearing them actually. Also, Space
Ghost, thank you for the two gifted subs before. Thank you. Thank
you. Um, yeah. Yeah, I I don't see where that test comes in.
And I do think that if if this were to go all the way, it is
going to get pushed to the point where you have to answer that
question. you essentially have no somebody tell me if I'm wrong
and somebody tell me if I've missed something but every time
that I've tried to look into like cases to do with digital media
or even to do with film when the question has been asked okay
how much of the original work was used I cannot find a single
case where the answer was all of it
yeah exactly oh my god I mean if somebody can find it send me
to it I haven't found it yeah that is the big thing um Yeah.
Yeah. But yeah, I know you want to get to the end of this, get
to sleep, and hold on. I won't take you. There's definitely a
line though, right? There is definitely a line. Like I do think
like the EFAP
uh like EFAP streams where they do like a whole movie. Would
it even be Yeah, it is EFAP, right? Where they do like a whole
movie over like 10 hours. I think that is I think that is absolutely
a case where you're not creating market replacement and you use
the whole thing and you would still want to watch the original
work or you would have already watched the original work. It
might not even be interesting to you if you'd never watched the
original work, right? So I think there is a line where you can
use the whole thing and I think you actually still pass all of
the pillars of fair use. I just don't I but I don't know like
maybe maybe there's some other argument there where if it's um
where if it's not where if it's like paywalled content then you
are creating a market replacement by reducing the price right
maybe there's some argument there but for free content I just
don't see how you could that's that's like a big thing too where
it's like okay the original work is not being charged for that
like it is freely available to most people there's no payw wall
well that that wouldn't be that would be determinant of damages
but I don't think that enters into the fair use exception or
the fair use analysis at all cuz where it talks about the nature
of the copyrighted work in terms of market replacement. Yeah.
But the barrier to entry isn't assessed in transformative
in in a fair use assessment so far as I've been able to tell.
Yeah. Yeah. It would be under transformative. It would be under
it would be under market replacement. Yeah. It would have nothing
to do with transformativity. It would be under market replacement.
No, sorry. that you're in terms of a a market replacement. I
don't know if it's been there. Usually, you're going to talk
about like are these like are these media onetoone uh and stuff
like that. I don't think I've seen anywhere where you have to
go and buy a movie versus watching a review of that movie that's
like free online, but they use some of the original work. I don't
think that that that that in and of itself has been asked. I
do see a lot of people assuming that and running with that, but
I haven't been able to find that like proven out anywhere, which
is scary as well because also the court. Would you find that?
Hold on. Would you find that on um like if people were suing
for watching like a boxing match, like a pay-per-view boxing
match? I think that could be where you'd find a precedent on
that. No.
Um would that not be for like scalping or just piracy kind of
retransmitting it? Well, I think I think you would DMCA those
streams, right? You'd have a copyright. That would be DMCA. That'd
be No, that'd be copyright infringement. But would there be any
use argument um for a transformation
if you're watching it like later comes out? Cuz that would fall
on every that would fall on every other single pillar
and also you're not adding anything to it. And so that is that
is a onetoone market effect. No, I'm saying like what if you
actually were watching live and pausing the whole time and doing
a bunch of [__] But wouldn't that be a market replacement
since you have to pay to watch the match regardless and if you're
watching them, you're not paying to watch the match. That is
my watch the match.
That would be interesting. Um
like you're like you're watching a boxing
to comment gone to like Yeah,
but you're already that's the difficult thing. I've tried to
look
and I just don't think that I have found any. I get the I get
the uh the analogy and it is one to one is exactly what I'm thinking
of. That would be a great place to test it. I don't think I've
seen those get DMCA. Yeah, most it mostly just gets DMCA I'm
pretty sure. Right. That's how that's how honestly most of the
most of the internet media stuff that's like actually copyright
infring. It just gets DMCA. Like most people don't actually take
this stuff to court. What's up, bro? Like repped off the platform.
Blessings.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. What's up?
Uh Ethan Klein stuff.
Yeah. Big fan of copyright law. Yeah.
I like copyright law. I think it's cool.
Um we're watching Pisco debate Hutch. Uh we also just went through
like another question that that but I think I think that to me
it's like uh apparently it was a thing that they were using intent
as like a fairly large portion of transformivity and then a higher
court determined like no no that's wrong. It actually shouldn't
really matter at all. It doesn't conclusively one way one way
or another shouldn't really matter. Shouldn't make a difference.
Shouldn't uh be hold on quintessential. It shouldn't be the the
the final thing in determining fair use. Yeah. Yeah. The thing
that the thing that I was saying though with the uh with the
market replacement and especially with re like kind of rereaming
stuff on YouTube, the courts aren't only going to be thinking
about okay digital creators and the digital space. What are they
kind of like using it for? They're also going to be speak they're
also going to be thinking about big studios. They're going to
think about copyright, you know, at large if they are ever going
to weigh on this stuff, which also does mean protecting big studios
with big budgets and trying to protect like it
expensive media, right? Not just like filming a YouTube video
in your bedroom like studios, budgets, casts, production, editing,
right? That's why I think the market replacement thing has to
include like some some thing where you become a significantly
better thing better replacement piece in the market by dropping
the price from $30 to free or yeah whatever. Like I think that
has to be included but maybe not. Oh, what is the Hutch Pisco
debate on this? Uh basically Ethan Klein's like intention with
his lawsuit. I see. Yeah, it is. It is on the like Denim's Casey
Tron Frogan
Yep. Yep. Yep. Did that happen today? Did what happen today?
Oh, uh yesterday. Yesterday. Yesterday. Anyway, yeah, I'll leave
you to it, mate. I'll be watching. Stay safe. All right. Have
a good day. Yeah, thanks for coming on. See you later. See you.
Chat to you later.
Yeah, we're just finishing this one up. It happened yesterday
and yeah, Hutch just came in and didn't know anything about the
case and kind of just got ragd doll by Pisco pretty hard. Yeah.
Yeah. What did he say that was? So, well, it's mostly on like
So, Pisco's assertion is essentially something like um Ethan
Klein lies about his intentions here. He doesn't want to get
criticized for potentially like um you know, risking React content
for a lot of people. He doesn't want to get criticized for going
after like anybody else. He just wants to so he's willing to
go against his principles which like he he set out in 2023 this
principle of like e basically if you react to a video in full
with very little commentary more or less copy the thumbnail in
the title you are like a parasite who is actually like super
detrimental to all content creation right and he was he had this
debate with XQC where he says XQC does this you're a piece of
don't do it and then when he goes to make his video now he says
remember when I discussed this in 2023 well I found something
even worse and then he says it's maliciously It's saying you
want to maliciously siphon money from me. That is what is worse.
And then he says uh XQC did watch it in full. Yes, but I don't
want to chill. That kind of reaction. So he basically gives XQC
a pass. And XQC is almost certainly a less substantial reaction
than Denim's reaction. Denim's reaction is 4 hours and XQC's
reaction is like 2 hours 15 minutes on an hour 30 hour 40-minute
video. So Denim's actually does have a substantial transformative
work in my opinion or at least far more substantial than XQC.
But to suing denims the question will be for will we will be
forced to ask the question hey is commenting over this work if
it's substantial and it's criticism and it's like you know a
response to some political arguments right even if even if that's
all the case if you react to the work in full could it possibly
be fair use we have to have that question asked for like live
streamers and that could set a precedent for all live streaming
where like the primary piece of content that almost all of us
do is no longer valid or is open to suing And that basically
chills like all criticism on the internet in so many ways. Like
all live stream criticism, all live streamers criticizing other
live streamers. It's going to chill all of that, right? Not necessarily.
I mean, just don't watch the thing in full.
Sure. So, you have to do like pre-work, but there won't be And
again, it'll lead to this whole thing where um people say you're
watching out of context or whatever. And yeah, you cannot watch
in full. That's true.
um for but then I don't I also don't know where that line is
versus like how much you can watch and yeah I I agree with the
idea it could open up the floodgates for like potential litigation
for drawing that line and the ambiguity of that line puts content
creators at a disadvantage because it's like oh if I react to
2 hours of this 4hour video is that too much or if I react to
one hour is that too much or three I don't disagree with that
but um as for the difference between XC and and venoms and all
that. I see that as a pretty, from my point of view, like common
sense difference. He may disagree and think that XQC is parasitic,
but he would want to handle that morally. The parasitic or the
malicious nature that he believes that um Denims is taking on
and that she overtly said um amongst others, he would see that
as fitting for legal action. So he dealt with XQC morally and
he just believes that maliciousness is worthy of illegal action.
Yeah. So what he says is he wants to set a precedent against
that maliciousness which essentially can't be done. You can't
set a precedent against that. Um like that is it's a strict liability
crime. Uh apparently in one of the pillars they used to think
intent was important. They used to think intent was uh like like
proof positive that if you intended if you didn't intend to transform
then you didn't. And then they overruled that and said it's more
about what a reasonable person would interpret. Did a does a
reasonable person think it's uh transformational or transformative
rather. Uh I think with denim stuff it absolutely is. Now there's
other stuff for the other pillars that will come into question
and be important as well. But it's I I think it's definitely
transformative. What he says here is he doesn't want to chill
but this is the important thing. He what he says is his motive
is not to chill like react streaming or commentary or criticism.
Essentially, it's like kind of what he's hinting at. He doesn't
want to chill that, but by suing Denims, he is going to force
a question that will allow for the chilling of that kind of speech
100%. Or it will potentially.
Yeah. Yeah. I wouldn't put that on him though. So, okay. Well,
he says his intention is not to do that and he is suing somebody
who he has a far worse case against in denims that will put that
question on the like uh like to a court. Yeah. But he's he's
in no control as to their adjudication of that. He's it's a byproduct
of him going after somebody he's he view as I mean it's not even
the view it's objectively true that are maliciously or were maliciously
trying to
uh siphon uh uh people from watching his thing their explicit
intent is that and yeah that's a byproduct of it but I wouldn't
put that on him as like a byproduct he's just saying this isn't
my intention is to chill speech but it may come as a consequence
but they're saying why even take the risk if that's the Right.
Because he doesn't want he doesn't purpose is to defend these
communities is to protect these communities. So it'll be the
first line of his lawsuit. Yeah. He doesn't want to
have malicious actors, people be able to just maliciously
snipe all of whatever. Yeah. Malice doesn't go into it though.
Like there are tons of there are movie reviewers on YouTube whose
taglines are literally I watched this so you didn't have to.
I played this game so you didn't have to. Should those people
all be open up to copyright suits? I think that's a very different
thing. When we're talking about that, we're usually talking about
people who are doing stuff. So, it's like, hey, this is communicating
directly to you that uh you can get a bunch of the information
that you would underlying inside of this from me. This maliciousness
that I wouldn't count that as malicious. I would count the maliciousness
in this instance being me and this community do not like this
guy. We are explicitly trying to reduce the amount of money that
this guy gets. They say it in no uncertain terms. They like I
play this game so you don't have to is meant to communicate that
oh I want to watch let's say Death Stranding. All of the information
necessary for that game comes from this let's play or this walkthrough.
I don't need to go anywhere else. Aren't you defining a market
replacement there? Yeah. Shouldn't you be if you want the experiment?
Yes. Excuse me. The issue is not a market replacement. the issues
issue is a malicious attempt at a market replacement. Okay. Where
is that where is that a part of the elements of copyright infringement?
I'm not sure that it is. The elements that I imagine would or
correlate with that would be under how uh that specific person
could defend their actions being transformative. Not whether
or not it is transformative but be like the intent for them in
the manner in which they were going about their transformative
content. So, if XQC were to say before firing up a stream and
falling asleep were to say, "I don't intend to infringe copyright
here," is that copyright infringement? I don't think that changes
the way that that works. Okay, so why does it
when he says, "I do want to steal this." Okay, but hold on. Is
it again, it's a strict liability crime? Like you you literally
your words don't really mean anything, right? It's whether or
not you did the thing. Like if you if you say like what Hold
on. What what prevents Denims from using this argument in court?
Um, I was playing a character. The character is obviously like
a person who doesn't like Ethan Klein. That is a part of my persona
on stream. Obviously, while I said these things, I made a significant
effort to transform the content. I I literally d more than doubled
the time. And while I understand what I said, that was not actually
my intent. Yeah. So, that would just be the believability of
whatever jury or judge it is presented upon. That's it. It's
just whether or not it's believable to that person. But I would
say that's like infinitely believable, right? No, it is not.
She obviously doesn't believe that. And every single reasonable
person you could say that she obviously transfor and I actually
don't necessarily agree with that. We might agree with that,
but I'm not sure a jury or a judge would find that to be
very very very very
possible.
Yeah, it's extremely possible actually that we would many different
juries, especially if you get like older people that would be
like, "Bro, this is you watch the whole video." And you said
that you explicitly wanted to create a market replacement explicitly
to not give this person money. You're a jury could straight up
just look at it that way. Uh I I truly believe because it's a
strict liability crime that it doesn't matter, right? The intent
is like worked out of it essentially on that front. are true
intent could possibly work into transformativity,
but she's not saying she doesn't
she's saying she doesn't intend she's saying she intends to create
a market replacement. I don't think intent goes into market replacement
at all. I think that is a straight up numbers analysis.
The question is whether or not that statement will get to be
admissible because whether or not we view it as a component would
be up to Ethan's
own judicial or sorry their uh legal team because the the motive
may not be the consequential thing for whether or not it is transformative
but it goes into
uh whether or like let's say it's ambiguous right let's say it's
up in the air if Ethan is allowed to submit that as like a point
of evidence and like worthy of consideration that would absolutely
change people's opinion as to whether or not there it is transformative
is whether or not they say they give a about it being transformative
or they explicitly want to do that. That is the idea. It's not
that hey is is she saying that make it so that way it is transformative.
It's people's opinion of her uh uh transformation,
their opinion of her work can be skewed by the fact that she
straight up says she doesn't care about it being transformative
and actually wants people to Yes. by saying, "Hey, I want anybody
who would otherwise watch this is going to watch this through
me and then not
transform. We should get the market market transformative market
replacement. Market replacement in my mind maybe not in a legal
sense. Market replacement in my mind is directly correlated with
transformative. If it is sufficiently transformative, it is its
own product in comparison to it being a market replacement. If
it is a market replacement, it is not transformative. Okay, I
see. No, they're not. That's not how it works. They're separate
pillars. Okay. That might work that legally. Sure. That might
not be how it works legally. I don't know the law and I'm I would
hesitate to I'd be inclined to not necessarily think that any
of us do. Maybe Pisco maybe on this. But like the idea that you
can be you can make a transformative work that is a market replacement.
I just don't do it that way. If it is transformative in my mind,
it is necessarily not a market replacement.
Okay. So, she didn't announce any intent not to transform it.
We're relying on you to stay live so we don't have to give the
nuke views. So that's from chat, right? She's reading a chat
message. Yeah, I'm going to stream it since he's confirmed it's
coming out today. I'm going to stream it. That is not any implication
that she is not going to transform it. Right. So as as I've No,
as I've said before, if it is sufficiently transformative, it
is not a market replacement. Sure. I'm I'm literally saying this
is not an intent to not transform it. Right. This right here.
Not necessarily.
Not that statement alone. No. Okay. Okay. And then the next statement
is, "Well, guys, if you enjoyed not giving any views to that
terrible video, give me a follow, subscribe, throw a prime if
you like my content." Yes. You think this is her
saying I don't know why you're doing this. In the in the totality
of all of her statements, she lays out a pretty, in my opinion,
obvious case for her not giving a about the transformativity
of the actual video. All she cares about is just like jerking
off with her audience to how much Ethan Klein is a loser for
that video. That is all that she cares about. And that is further
boosted by the fact that people are coming into her chat saying,
"Hey, I would watch this video, but I don't want to give it views,
so I'm going to go to you." And then her, as you pointed with
some of these statements, double downing on that. That's what
I would further compound with her. I don't think she doubled
down on this except at the very end where she said, "Let's like,
I'm happy we didn't watch that." But I Are there more quotes?
What are the rest of the quotes?
What do you mean? What are you referring to? The quotes that
I'm talking about where Yeah. What are the other What are Do
you know where the other Did you get the other statements from
a video you watched or did you watch her reaction? No. No. I'm
talking
this idea. Are you talking about the idea in my mind that Denims
does not care about the transformativity of it? Is that what
you're referring to? Okay. It's I It comes through in my opinion.
I don't have direct quotes. No, I I could look for stuff, but
it comes through in my opinion based on people inside of her
audience saying stuff like that, but also that she her whole
intent, as I understand it, to be to just circle jerk about how
much this guy is a person. And that that's the primary that's
the primary motive of it is to do that. And I think this is the
spirit of Ethan Klein's lawsuit. It is fine if you're XQC and
you want to react to a video and provide lackluster commentary.
I'm going to be morally against you. Where I find it morally
egregious is when you create a whole apparatus for harassment
and then you explicitly
say that you are trying to siphon views. You are trying to uh
siphon exposure from the video. That is what he's explicitly
trying to target is it should not be okay to set up a harassment
campaign and then watch somebody's video with the deliberate
intent to siphon exposure. That should not be okay. That should
not be legal. Legal. That is his argument. I think I So where
is that argument coming from? What do you mean? That's his video.
That is literally his video. Why do you Okay, actually genuine
question. Why do you think he added XQC in that video? Um because
he wanted to explain why he wasn't going to sue XQC.
Why do you think it was important in his mind to not to explain
why he wasn't going to sue XQC?
Because he wants XQC's audience supporting him. You you genuinely
believe that? I genuinely believe that the reason he did that
is because he wants XQC's audience supporting him and not being
against him. And he has he has actually criticized XQC before
and he explicitly puts him in there and says, "But I don't want
to kill this guy." Even though that guy is literally stealing
his content, stealing money from him directly. So why do you
think it you Yes. And you don't think it's possible, maybe possible
that exactly what I described is his motive. He doesn't want
to chill speech that he thinks might be immoral, but not necessarily
something he should go after legally. You think
by going after denims? You can't go after he isn't. That's not
true. You don't know that. That needs to be adjudicated. It might.
No, it's literally it's literally not a part of like what she
said here is not a part of the elements. It cannot be adjudicated.
It cannot be I I am pretty confident that they cannot say well
actually if you say that you wanted to steal money from this
person that means you're guilty. They can't do that. They will
never ever do a narrow ruling like that. And the things they
actually have to rule on are things that will affect XQC because
XC is a far more egregious reactor than Denims is. They're not
going to take into account the fact that Ethan and and Denims
had a feud before this unless it's to be positive towards Denim
Denims and say she had implied license because they had reactions
back and forth over and over and over again. Listen, you don't
know this. I don't know this. It is entirely possible that they
could bring up the context of those specific statements as to
show the overarching uh or put into a greater context her transformative
her quote unquote transformative elements on that video. You
don't know that that is possible that they could do that as an
argument against or for the transformativity of her the elements
that she put on. Why wouldn't be Why do you think it couldn't
be transformative to just talk Ethan while you do this? I I never
said it wasn't. I never said it wasn't. Why do you think it's
impossible? It It is totally impossible that Ethan's lawy legal
team could ever in any way, shape, or form bring up those quotes.
Why do you think it's impossible? I don't think it's impossible.
It would be okay. So, if it's possible, in what context could
they bring it up? I don't know what quote you're talking about.
Are you talking about the two quotes at the beginning or are
you talking about other quotes? Yes. The the the statements of
like her saying
like, "I'm glad you can you're live so we can watch this." They're
they're bringing these up to say it is proof that she's creating
a market replacement. No, no. I'm asking is there any reality
where that is admissible in
Um
yeah, probably in terms of
deciding on statutory damages or not. I believe that if this
goes to judgment, if this goes to like a a jury to to decide
liability that they will be told that hey this actually in terms
of copyright infringement, this can't be considered. So no, no,
I'm not asking whether or not you think. I'm asking whether it's
a 0% possibility because you are making
possibility. Okay. So then I I don't know why you're acting like
this has no elements. You don't know. I don't know. Probably
Pisco doesn't even know. I don't think Pisco is a copyright lawyer.
But either way, Pisco is making pretty strong statements about
how because these aren't a part of the elements like you would
have to you would like basically have to read new lines into
the law, right? To rule to rule. No, you wouldn't. No, no, you
wouldn't. you that's not necessarily true that you would because
what you're referring to is in order for it to be considered
in the process of it like her those statements being whether
or not it is transformative conclusively oh it was transformative
but you said this therefore it's not transformative that isn't
the argument the argument would be that in the the
u in the context of her trans her transformative elements right
in the context of her transform formative elements. Does this
color how the jury feels about it and would it then be admissible?
That's it. Because there is no hard line. There is no hard proof.
It is about how does the jury feel feel. It is literally a gut
feeling that we're talking about here about the transformativity.
So would
transform nothing is concluded. Go ahead. I I don't see how I
I just don't see if you want to make an argument for how this
could be like we could talk about it but I do not see how these
comments color transformability I abs I absolutely do. So, for
instance, let's say that with let's say the only thing that Denim
said inside of a 10-second video is
um like wow, literally the word wow, right? And let's say that
there was some debate as to whether or not that was transformative.
Her saying, yeah, I I literally make no effort to transform any
of the content that I react to. I don't care. I'm a like content
thief and a pirate. I could easily see how people could be who
are on the fringe could be like those are comments on transforming
but these aren't comments on transforming these these comments.
Okay, we disagree on that because I view a transformative work
as definitionally not being a market replacement. If it is a
market replacement, it is not transformative. It is literally
the four pillars of fair use based like I understand that but
you're saying like I you're just saying you don't live in reality,
right? No, I'm just saying no. I would just say that this is
how I personally view it. What do you mean I don't live in reality?
I we can have separate definitions. Maybe even my
is something that basically reduces the value of the other work
by existing. Yes. Yes. And so like whether or not you've transformed
it like that that is a question outside of whether you reduce
it like you have to analyze. Is that hold on is that is that
even is that even true? If I hold on I'm sure there's a correlation.
I'm sure this is a true if I upload if I upload Hold on. If I
upload in a Disney Pixar movie right now to YouTube and there
is not a single human being who has ever viewed it, would you
say that it is not no court would ever find me liable for copyright
infringement because no human being has ever seen it? Um, yeah.
I mean, I think these have to be I think there have to be actual
damages for No, no, no. I don't believe that. No, no, no. You
may there may have to be actual damages for you to like get some
kind of lump sum of cash, but the idea that I couldn't that you
genuinely believe that I could not upload I can upload a full
Disney movie right now and as long as nobody has seen it, it
is not illegal. Oh, okay. Yeah. No, I think I think it literally
has to be viewed by somebody. If it just never gets uh you could
get DMCA, but I don't think you could ever go to court. I don't
think you could ever get taken to court over it. I think that
would be absolutely frivolous litigation. You could get DMCA
aid, but I do not think who's ever watched it. You could possibly
be like sued for copyright infringement. Okay, we we could maybe
maybe that's a thing. Maybe that's I think I would disagree with
that on the merits. Maybe that's a thing though. Um
but uh
no, I would I would say that it's probably like not the case.
But either way, let
I feel like the like it has to be observed by somebody else in
some way. I I don't think that I mean we could just Google it.
Uh you you could it's possible with these statuto things, but
that seems like Yeah.
I mean, you're literally just asking is fair use
you're literally just asking does fair use apply to something
with literally no transformative elements as long as it's not
viewed by anybody? That's what you're asking. Well, I'm sorry.
I'm saying you wouldn't be liable for copyright infringement
because there have to be damages. If you're saying does it is
it fair use if that's a different thing also I've been up for
like a long time I'm pretty exhausted. So if you're saying if
it's is it fair use? No. Is that not what Ethan Klein is is is
suing over is fair use over copyrighted material. Copyright infringement.
And I believe I believe copyright infringement. So you you apply
this four element standard to the material. I think it fails
this but I don't think a court would like really hear it. So
when you're talking about copyright infringement, the means to
be able to get out of copyright infringement is fair use. Correct.
It's either you did not use any of the underlying copyright material
or you use the copyrighted material under fair use. Correct.
Those are the only two ways you get out of copyright infringement.
Am I wrong? Yes. But I think like essentially this is meant to
be like
I'm I feel like you might be able to do it, but it feels like
one of those things where it's like, oh, this was seen by nobody.
Nobody's ever seen this. I have no idea. You You might It'll
probably get thrown out because somebody Nobody's going to give
a to see it. That's what I'm saying. It's illegal. If you just
want to say if it's fair use or not, it's not DMCA. It would
be like It would be like against a platform's rules. Yes. So,
I think what you're asking me is if it's if it's in violation
of fair use. It would be in violation of fair use. Okay. So,
I'm saying practically I think it's like not heard. That's not
relevant to our conversation though. We're not talking about
it's whether or not it's going to be heard or not heard by a
judge or a jury. We're talking about their conclusions. So practically
is it fair use? No. There you go. Okay. So
um the idea then that copyright
uh uh on the basis of it just being uh I forget how we got here.
It's like we got here arguing about transfer like basically is
a work. So to me whether commenting on whether a work is a market
replacement is not indicative whatsoever of whether or not it's
transformative. Right? Her saying I wish to replace this in the
market. I wish to siphon views from this is not her saying I
am not transforming. These are not connected. No it it would
connect to um whether or not they have an intent to transform.
It would inform them whether or not they have an intent to transform.
They've stated that they don't care about transforming. I don't
believe that's the case. Okay. If we establish that a market
replacement
is because we had I I believe by that argument we've established
that a market replacement is by definition not transformative.
It is transformative is not a market replacement. Correct. Because
your definition of market replacement was something that directly
uh negatively affects the original product which we just went
through. Correct. And you're saying that you you believe if something's
transformative, it definitely can't be a market replacement.
What makes something transformative? What makes something transformative?
Uh the idea that it is a substantially like different thing that
you have you have tried to make some artistic statement that
adds to it that turns it into a different kind of work. Okay.
And by that definition, do you think that that separate new thing
can be or is a market replacement definitionally?
Yes. Okay. I disagree. I think if it is a separate thing, if
it is a separate and distinct thing, by my definition, it would
not be a market replacement. And even that separate thing, even
if it hurts the underlying like let's say uh uh the bottom line
of the other product, right? Let's talk about like a small streamer
making a very well put together video and a large streamer just
comes in and yolks it and steals a bunch of let's just say in
theory it steals steals a bunch of exposure that think this is
a transformative work going from photo one to photo two. Yeah,
I'd say so. Okay. I mean the person says that they had no intent
to transform it. Uh I mean I don't care that much. I would need
to see overall context of some of the stuff that they've done
but it doesn't even really matter. It's very obviously transformative
to me. Okay. And you think Denim's reaction to this stream was
less transformative than this? I don't I didn't watch all of
Denim's 4-hour VOD, so I don't know how I didn't watch the whole
thing either, but do you do you So her her VOD seems to more
than double the length, right? That doesn't matter at all to
me. Are you claiming there's like dead air in the denims or something?
Yeah, I was.
She could have left. She could have left. She could have just
been sitting there like not really doing much at all. I I don't
get up and I don't know I don't know the exact Sure, but she
could have just sat there and not really reacted to much. She
might have just been getting a lot of woes, wows, I can't believe
he said that. Uh wow, that's crazy. And stuff like that. He could
have been there could have been a lot of that. I don't know.
The length is not a good argument for me unless it's like ridiculous.
And even still, I would have to look at the the context. The
length is not a good argument. I've reacted to Destiny VODs for
that. I've tripled the length of some Destiny VODs and I promise
you that that is not transformative. I mean, how could it not
be? Why Why would somebody go and watch your VOD with like
obnoxious laughter through the whole thing? Why would somebody
go watch that when they could just watch the original and save
themselves time just cuz they were on they were live that or
they were on Twitch that day, didn't look at the YouTube or whatever
and they saw I was watching the video and they just decided to
stay. Okay, then how are you replacing them in a market they
don't compete in? I'm not. Oh, not replacing them. Okay. But
you still feel like it's not transformative even though you've
tripled the length with laughing and saying a bunch of like weird
You don't think it's transformative? You don't think that's a
fundamentally different piece of art? Oh, you're talking about
in this hypothetical or whatever. Yeah. No, in the hypothetical.
Yeah. No, I'd be I'd be Are you referring to like damages when
I'm talking about market replacement or what are you referring
to? saying you've I'm I'm saying I believe if you triple the
length of it laughing in between I do think that's transformative.
Really? Yes.
Doing nothing but laughing. You think that's sufficiently transformative?
Well, I think you probably do more than nothing but laughing,
but yes. Okay. Well, just in that hypothetical, I didn't know
whether or not we were talking about in reality or
What are these? There's like uh there's like a list of things
for transformativity here.
Where is it? Where's the preamble? I'm looking for this preamble.
Where is it?
Purpose of the use is transformative. This makes the first factor
more likely to favor fair use. Although when the purpose of the
use is transformative, this makes the first factor more likely
to favor fair use. Okay.
Formativeness is central to the fair use analysis since 19
standard. God, there's like a preamble here that I'm looking
for that says like the things we're looking for in this. Does
anybody know if a copyright lawyer is taking a look at this?
Um, uh, I read an article from a copyright lawyer that I think
was actually just mostly chat GBT that claimed that this is very
likely to say for copyright. No, no, no, no, no. Actual copyright
lawyer that Aaron linked me.
Huh? Uh, why can I not find the I'll just find a different thing
for this. I was just curious because I saw a bunch of like for
lack of a better term normally lawyers and they were pretty pro-
Ethan, but I didn't know if it was just W glaze or what. Oh,
I think No, I think probably what's going to come up here. So,
again, I actually I think I would lean towards Denim's losing.
I I think Denims is like 8020 not going to pass this on fair
use. Maybe maybe 9010 not going to pass this on fair use. But
the issue for me is that Ethan claims to not want to chill this
kind of reaction,
but he is suing somebody where that will by definition have to
be answered, where he will by definition open up everybody to
be liable, everybody who does this kind of content.
Uh potentially, but extremely likely this question almost almost
literally has to be answered. Can you include a full video in
your commentary on a live stream and and still be fair use? That
question has to be answered for them to make a judgment on this
case. Correct. I don't think that that question is definitively
going to be like a no. You cannot do that. I don't believe that
that's going to be but I'm saying there's a likely chance that
it will be and I think the question has to be answered and the
ambiguity there is what prevents a bunch of other people from
filing lawsuits on this stuff. And I think if that question is
answered and the answer is no, I think you won't be able to do
fullyfledged reactions to things if you're going to be critical.
But I think you will be able to do fully fed fledged reactions
to things if you are going to suck the person's. Okay. And I
think that is a terrible environment to operate in where like
as long as I suck this person's I can do whatever content I want
and all critical reaction is actually out the window because
if I'm critical enough I can just be sued.
I think that's a horrible environment to this for operate in.
What makes you think that? Wait, are you referring to the critical
versus non-critical bias as being the likelihood that somebody
will take you to court over it? Yes. Okay. Um, yeah. I mean,
I just I don't view that as like genuinely, let's say she's
determined as being guilty of
um, you know, copyright infringement. I don't think that's definitive
that you can't review a an entire piece of work in its entirety.
I think it would be based on the substance of your transformativity.
Well, they'll have to come up with some line for why they found
it this to justify why they wouldn't would or wouldn't find this
to be fair use. Right. I Yeah, I I feel pretty confident they're
not going to say, well, just if you watch a thing in full, therefore
it's not transformative. I mean, it's possible if they get a
bunch of like maybe like boomer people on like the Do these things
have a Do these specific cases have juries? I don't know which
cases have juries and which ones don't. I don't I don't know
if this one does or don't. Uh they are seeking a jury trial for
this. Like it could be a bunch of boomers and they're just like
I mean just watching a full video that seems pretty stupid. They
could just do that. I don't know. But people wanted to give more
give royalties to original creators. Guess that went nowhere.
It does go nowhere. That is what everybody wants. That is literally
the solution everybody would like is just let me automatically
give royalties to this person. Yeah, that'd be perfect. That's
what it's just a difficult thing to set up. But yeah, it's uh
it's difficult. Uh we could totally argue this. Oh, go go go
go. Yeah. No, I'll just do a like a final thing because I know
you said you're retired. Um, my idea is just that Ethan wants
to go after what he views as like people who hate you and want
to
uh um siphon exposure from your video. That's what he's looking
to do is is
try and get people who uh um you know are malicious or or hate
you hate your community doing that thing and he's trying to prevent
that culture from becoming totally Yeah. Okay. Well,
uh I I understand how he's presenting it. I
feel like it is just basically going after his critics.
Um it uh I I think if that was the case, I feel like he'd be
going after more people. Um like who? Yeah, Mike from PA. Mike
from Preactive. I can't remember. Well, he reacted to a ton of
stuff that he could go after. No, to a ton of clips and stuff.
Maybe. Yeah. I mean, I think he's clearly going after this because
of the um he can do statutory damages, right? That's the whole
purpose of this. You're aware he like registered this with the
Library of Congress so that he could apply statutory damages
here because he probably doesn't have real actual damages. Sure.
Okay. I mean I mean if they find Denim's liable she watch it
in front of 50,000 people. I think you could maybe claim some
exposure. I genuinely don't know. There would probably be some
actual damages, but it would be less than probably less than
$10,000.
I probably I don't know. I genuinely don't know how that specifically
works.
Yeah. Oh, yeah. This is another good point. Do you think the
malicious intent thing is actually a real standard here? What
do you mean?
So, he registered this before he ever put the content nuke out
and then he said he registered it because he wanted to catch
all these react streamers reacting to his video because he wanted
to sue them. So, he wanted to apply statuto damages to a certain
group of people he hates, right? And he had no way of knowing
that they would come out and say, "Oh, actually this guy, we
want to take views away from him." He had no way of knowing that,
right? When he registered it and made this plan in the first
place.
So he So why did he have this plan before he even knew this happened?
Why did he have the plan to sue these
The idea would be that he would kind of put himself in a position
where if they did something like this, he would be able to sue
them. No. Oh, so no. because he literally said himself, I couldn't
dream of them being stupid enough to give me this this ability
the like to say this. So that wasn't a part of his rationale
for registering it. And he registered it with the intent to sue
these people. And what's what's the problem? It it seems like
it's just a post hawk rationalization to try to deflect criticism,
right? He's going after people because he wants to punish because
he wants to punish people, but he wants to do so without getting
criticism back himself. And so this rationalization
if that was true, why isn't he suing Assan? Because Hassan absolutely
is an implied license. Okay. So he then the argument would be
that he does understand what is the line and what isn't the line.
He viewed that they crossed the line and that Assan didn't. Therefore
they went he went after them and not Hassan had an implied license.
Hassan had an implied license. Ethan invited him to watch it
like a hundred times. Oh sure. Then why didn't he invite or why
didn't he sue Shonda Black then initially? I don't even know
anything about Shawn Black's reactions. I don't know if he was
malicious. I don't know if he I don't know what his I don't I
don't I don't know if he was a I don't know if he was also are
aware that he has said he was just kidding about suing Shondaanda
Black, right? Oh, I I thought he was legitimate. I thought it
was a legitimate thing. I also think I also don't think he knew
about it. That's why the whole snitching thing. I don't think
he Shawn Black was on his radar thing.
Um no, Shonda Black was on that list from H3 Stark. Shonda Black
was on that list from H3 Stark. He had to be on the radar. But
uh are you aware that he like also tried to so he said he was
suing him and then he basically said to a bunch of other people
he was like hey um if you guys like apologized to me I won't
sue him and then he messaged and then he like added Hassan not
added Hassan he just basically addressed Hassan and said yeah
well since these people are too cowardly to apologize to me um
Hassan if you donate 25k to each of the three women's uh gofundmes
then I'll drop my lawsuit against Shondaanda Black. So, he was
doing like this weird just super weird I have no idea why he
would do this. And then after basically like nobody responded
to him, he went, "Ah, just kidding. I'm not suing Shawn Black."
Well, I mean, I don't approve of the like kind of ransoming
um there. I don't approve of that. I don't think that's a good
thing to do. No. Is Ethan's extortion Instagram post ruined his
court case? Oh, maybe. I I doubt it. But if he had a real case,
I don't think I don't think those posts would mean he wouldn't
have a real case anymore. Sorry, I was answering a chat message.
Yeah, he's uh man. So again, I think he planned to sue these
people before he ever knew that they would say this malicious
intent thing. Before um before they displayed it, before he had
any idea they would display it, he planned to sue them. I I think
he was I think he was ready to I think he was ready to sue them,
not plan to sue sue them. Uh well, he was going to sue them explicitly.
So, so the the copyright with this with the Library of Congress
is a strategy that Dan Saltman described explicitly on my stream.
He registers anything else with the Library of Congress so that
he can DMCA people for uh statutory damages, which is basically
saying like if you violate this this uh this copyright, I don't
care if you've made like $5 from it. I don't care if you made
$10,000 from it. I'm going to make it so that you pay damages
to me that are way out whatever the actual damages are. Right?
That's like the whole point. And then he gave this strategy to
Ethan and then Ethan registered this with the intent he says
to have these people react to it in full and so he could sue
them for doing so. So I think his motivation his like plan from
the beginning was to sue these people who reacted to it in full
uh his enemies who reacted to I I don't think so regardless of
circumstance. I don't think it's regardless of circumstance.
Well, I think I think his stated thing was if they provided no
transformative uh like whatever it was them, the people he doesn't
like, if they reacted to it in full without substantial commentary,
then he could sue them. Then he would sue them. Correct. Yeah.
What's wrong with that? Uh it just proves that the malicious
intent is not a part of his rationale for suing people. It's
just like a post hawk thing. It's not necessarily it could it
could more make him want to sue, but he was planning to sue anyway.
like this wasn't why he devised this plan. And I believe so here's
the question. If Casey Tron had never said uh something along
the lines of like we're doing this to take views away from Ethan
Klein, if she'd never said that, do you think he wasn't going
to sue Casey Tron? If Frogan had ever said anything like that,
you think he wasn't going to sue Frogan? I I I think it's more
likely that he would not than he would on the basis that the
only people that he sued were the people that definitively said
that they were maliciously stealing from him. But okay, outside
of Caseyron, Froggen and Denims have been like the two objects
of his eyeire for the past like what year and a half. So he clearly
believes he has a case. He has a case regardless of the malicious
intent declaration. You think he would pass up suing Frogan after
all the Frogan said about him? Yeah, I have I believe I have
more evidence to imply that he would pass up suing them by the
fact that he is suing not a single person that didn't say those
things than like I I would say that's more paramount to the fact
that he's suing Casey Tron. I don't feel like Casey Tron was
super on his radar even in comparison to like Shondaanda Black
and stuff because like obviously Shondaanda Black was in the
content cop for an example, right? And I the idea that Casey
Trron got dragged in, I think more implies that he was specifically
targeting these people because of the malicious statements they
made. Okay. I need an example of somebody who reacted to it in
full who was
uh equally or more harassing towards Ethan that he passed up
suing. That's what I would need. I think you would I think you
would need to provide me the opposite because you're assuming
that his stated purpose is not his stated purpose. You're assuming
that that without a single example of him suing one of these
people without them stating a malicious intent. I'm just saying
by the fact he only is suing people who stated malicious intent
and one of the people wasn't even like one of the flag bearers
that that to me is like okay yeah I'll at the very least just
give it to him because I have no significant reason to believe
he's lying or not telling the truth. Um, I think given his like
when he signed up for this stuff and how he's handled basically
the whole thing. I think given his um what was it that uh he
reregistered his stream or he registered his stream after way
after Denim's reacted to it because he knew that probably there's
no argument that uh like like he knew that she did make significant
efforts to transform the the content nuke, right? Like to try
to have her on another thing like he registered after she had
reacted. So, he's suing him for two things, right? The the reaction
to the content nuke and to the stream before the countdown to
doomsday, right? Oh, I didn't know most I didn't know the count
I didn't know the countdown to doomsday thing. Well, and again,
the the chair react is to um the countdown to doomsday, which
by the way, he totally lies about in the video. Like he he makes
it very he he very clearly implies that she chair reacted to
the content nuke, which she didn't do. um it was like during
the stream before that, but um so he does both of them and that's
because in my opinion that he was a little concerned that it's
possible that the content nuke could be uh what do you call it
like declared transformative her reaction to it but with the
stream it's pretty unlikely cuz she doesn't really do much for
commentary. Don't know then I mean maybe I I don't know I would
have to see it. I think he wanted to sue these people like no
matter what. I think if the malicious statements had not come
out of Denims, Denims would still be getting sued. I think he
basically tried to create a rationale that he could put out there
that is less questionable, less like open to criticism than anything
else. So he basically just did his calculation after the fact
and was like, "Oh, these people said this. Okay, I can sue enough.
I get like enough damage if I do it this way." That's that's
how it looks to me because to me he had the intent to sue them
from the beginning before and he said as much like I was going
to sue these people. I had no idea they'd say these things. Right.
Well, he said he would find it out. Yeah. He said he would sue
them if they did not provide
substantial commentary. Correct. Yeah. And I mean is is that
wrong or I I don't understand what the problem is. Well, he's
suing Denims now even though she gave substantial commentary
fundamentally risking the chilling effect on all the people he
said he didn't want to chill. Sure. If we assume that she provided
substantial commentary then
yeah it's uh or because I don't know what you what you've seen
uh about it. I'm saying substantial given like the culture like
I think her commentary is probably about the on the same level
as like Asmin Golds in terms of substantiality which I don't
know if you so I I think there's a misnomer about Asold because
he puts out so much content that he doesn't actually like give
good commentary. He absolutely does like he does he gives like
transformative commentary like he does he does comment a lot.
He's got his own opinions. I might think they're [__]
of the time but they're there. They exist. Um,
I don't know. I I mean, sure, if we use him as the standard,
then maybe I don't know. I would have to have to view,
again, I would have to view more of her reaction to the I I just
find it very weird that he he literally holds up Asmin Gold and
XQC and goes, "I don't want to chill these guys." XQC being somebody
who literally is is every element of badness that he's ever described
about this before this exact moment and he goes, "I'm giving
XQC a pass, but I'm suing Dennis." Yeah, he's giving he's giving
them a pass legally.
Oh, that confusion that thing doesn't confuse me at all. There's
a lot of people who I do think do a lot of unethical. Hassan
is one of them. I think he's quite unethical with a lot of his
reactions to a lot of content. If he ever reacted to my content
in the manner that he does, I wouldn't assume though because
I don't think it reaches the level of what should be illegal.
I think it's not right morally, but I don't think it should be
illegal. Yeah. I'm saying that if he wanted to go against people
who were lazy reactors, if he actually took the the initial
initial rationale, XQC would be a far better target and far less
likely to chill the exact kind of commentary he says he doesn't
want to chill, right? like he he would not be risking it in the
same way he risks it through suing Denims. So I think the I think
he's just ling
I don't know what you mean by the initial I what I felt when
I watched that video is and this was massively substantiated
by his direct comparisons of Asmin and Xuc is I do not want to
chill speech that or reactions
that are lazy. I want to chill lazy
uh malicious reactions. That's what he wants to show. You could
say whether or not uh Denims had a lazy reaction or a more or
less lazy. He doesn't care about lazy reactions from a legal
standpoint. He cares about it from a moral but not a legal standpoint.
He thinks that lazy malicious reactions should be curtailed legally.
Sure. So he can't get that like narrow there's no way he can
ensure that narrowness given he's suing Denims. is working against
that that like that's his argument is you're saying because
only go after these narrow things, right? Because Denim's reaction
is significantly more transformative than a ton of other ones,
right? Yeah. So that would just that would just be an argument
to his stupidity. You would just argue that not that there's
an issue with his premises, but that there's uh what is it? His
argument is valid but not sound. That's would be your argument.
There's nothing wrong with his premises. The issue is just that
they're not sound. Well, I think No, there is something wrong
with the Well, sure, sure, sure. If if he could narrow this down
and only like silent if he could feasibly do that, um, then this
could make sense, but you can't feasibly do that. Well, you can't
they can't you can't feasibly do it from your point of view.
It could be possible that they view or you're saying that if
if Denims is found in breach of
you're saying from your point of view that if Denim is found
in breach of two rational okay he wants to protect he wants to
protect everybody from lazy malicious reactions because he's
worried about Disney and whoever is suing people right and he
doesn't want to chill commentary of people who are just doing
like slightly lazy reactions or on the line reactions okay those
are his Yep. He is violating the second goal explicitly by trying
to sue Denims. You could argue from a soundness point of view,
but from a validity point of view, not necessarily. But wait,
are all supposed to be sound the whole
is it not literally facious?
Yeah, it is. Like it means the argument doesn't make sense if
it's not sound. No. Am I crazy? I'm making I'm making the argument
from his point of view. from making the argument that he is mentally
ill that he is having a saying like relativist you want to make
not in touch with reality
no this is a very basic idea if Ethan can believe that legally
this their stated intent of
explicitly trying to siphon exposure would warrant them to extra
penalties or consideration by the court he can believe that he
can also believe that they engaged engaged in lazy reactions.
That is a not even can he believe it. I think that is a very
reasonable interpretation
from his point of view and from many people's point of view knowing
this group, knowing these people and stuff like that, not necessarily
having watched the totality of their content, the totality of
their reactions because it wouldn't even surprise me if Ethan
hasn't watched all of the uh Denim's reaction. Or maybe he has
and maybe he is biased. But either way, it is totally possible
that he could believe those two things. And as long as he believes
those two things that are kind of reasonable, that is it for
his argument to be made that he is specifically targeting lazy
malicious reactions and that he from his perspective will not
uh um necessarily have a fallout on just lazy reactions. I do
I don't even believe that that's his argument in his own lawsuit.
I believe he is she's in his own lawsuit that that Denims gives
bad commentary. Not like lazy commentary, incorrect commentary.
Like she is
maybe that's true. And it's it's not even that it's lazy, it's
that it's like wrong. I disagree. Sure. Uh may maybe that's the
case. I haven't read all of the details of his lawsuit. Maybe
in the explicit lawsuit, I'm referring primarily to the video,
but maybe in the lawsuit it says explicitly, hey, the reason
why this content isn't transformative is because it's dumb or
wrong. I don't I don't think that is in consideration for the
courts. I don't think that they're going to consider whether
or not you're wrong as to the merits of transformativity. I doubt
it, but um I'm not a lawyer. Uh
but that idea that's all that's needed is that for him to believe
that the lazy and then malicious commentary and that those things
can be a factor in a legal case which to be clear lawyers believe
as well. One thing you cannot deny is that there are lawyers
that are actively talking online right now that say that because
they said those things it's not looking good for them. That can
hurt them in court. Whether that's legitimate or not, those there
are that lends credence to the idea that a reasonable person
could interpret those statements as being factors in a legal
case.
Um, case that's all he needs. I I need to find the law tubers
who are saying like that explicitly where like because Okay,
there was a intent. There was a guy he was he's on LSF. Let me
see if I can't find him. Wearing a blue suit. Wearing a blue
suit. I don't remember the color of his suit. He's wearing a
suit though. Legal mindset. Yeah, the base. Yeah, maybe legal
mindset. Yeah. What? Pull his video. I don't hate legal mindset.
You're the one who hates legal mindset. No, I'm a legal mindset
fan. I was a legal mindset fan during um when did he first pop
up? Hold on. I can't remember videos here. Uh this guy wears
like a lot of blue suits all the time. Yeah. Yeah, he was one
of them. Yeah, he was one of them. Okay. Okay. Oh, the legal
mind fans in freshman fit time, man. Let's see which one would
it be. Where's the first Ethan Klein Klein? Ethan Klein's copyright
trap. Fast facts. Let's see if we can find the word intent in
here. Intent. Find this in the I'm not finding in the transcript
here.
Not in the transcript. Malice.
Oh, mh malice. may even be malice on the part of many of these
parties who literally intended it to be for a to be a substitute
to Ethan's content to his copyright protected content and that
is a top issue. Now Ethan did say one thing which I need to clear
up because there needs to be some So is that a top issue? So
I would assume that means for the court this guy is by the way
just so you know this guy is like legally. Okay. This guy is
like he said you'd hit him. Well, I mean, when he first reviewed
the Destiny stuff, he reviewed the Florida cyber harassment law
and basically was like, "No, no, no. I think like Destiny stuff
could fall under that because um like even though it's just audio,
I think like even though it says visual depiction here, this
audio could totally follow follow it." Like I'm I'm pretty sure
he he like just he like actually hit a stroke and covered it.
It was kind of rough baseline about what copyright is and what's
going on with copyright. So let's listen to Ethan here talking
about him registering that copyright and I'll explain things
as we One thing about copyright you should know is that you got
to register it before you publish to be eligible for statuto
damages and attorney's fees which is the main biting force of
so he says he talks about malice here he says it's a top issue
to me that means he thinks it's important to the legal case the
actual legal case but I am not sure
I think there there was a separate clip of him talking about
it um that uh it might have been in this video where he talked
about it and it he said that it wasn't looking good for um as
a result of that discovery which means Ethan Klein is going to
get them and ultimately we the people we the public are probably
going to get to see some of those that is going to be gold to
see the conversations that they had and the intent behind them
because you know these people weren't careful in their emails
and DMs these people were malicious these people were I I guarantee
you I don't need to see them to know this I guarantee you they
would gonna be killer and I think this is going to change this
guy literally this guy literally just takes he He He's so smart
and so absurd at the same time. He literally just takes whatever
opinion is going to make him the most money.
Absolutely every time. He He's just making He doesn't even know
that these people would exist. He doesn't know any of this. I
love this guy. He's just like He just makes it up. It's so funny.
I feel like the opinion that would make him the most money would
probably be siding with Assan. Why? Why? You know it's you have
a lot of these guys are like traction on the right person adjacent
to Hassan is making like a lot of money.
What are you talking about? Like you get a lot more coverage.
It's controversial. You get What are you talking about? Are these
guys? If he was one if he was one of the only lawyers who was
saying this Ethan Klein lawsuit is totally bogus if and with
his platform he could cause a lot of controversy and get a lot
of He doesn't have to say it's totally bogus. I'm looking for
his thing on maliciousness. I'm saying he's going way in the
other direction. He's saying like, "Oh, these DMs are going to
be so good." And it's like like you don't even know that any
DMs between like Denims and this group exist. You're just like,
you're just like saying that. Okay, hold on. Hold on. This is
probably the part I think this could be the part right here.
I think we are forgetting the chilling effect of Hassan's orbit
losing. People like Sniperwolf going to be terrified to just
sit down. because they
judges don't make it clear it's because it substitutely
siphon views then there is going to be a chilling effect and
that is true people like Sniperwolf is going to be terrified
to justice yeah hold on people are forgetting the chilling effects
orbit losing yeah no I'm I mentioned that I'm not forgetting
that Nate I mentioned that and that's the one thing I don't like
about this and I want the judges if they rule in Ethan's favor
to make it very freaking clear that this is specifically because
they said it. Because otherwise, if the judges don't say that
and don't make it crystal clear, it's because these people made
it obvious. Oh, I would love to know why he thinks they can say
that. Why he thinks they can
like a rational I would love to know. I would love to know. Back
to copyright infringement. She had paid profits. They were done
with actual and constructive knowledge and they were willful,
intentional, malicious or taken with reckless disregard for their
rights. That's all true. Their second claim is against the mods.
The mods facilitated.
They knew this would infringe on copyright. They are responsible
and they materially contributed. Because of that, they suffered
damages
and they had constructive knowledge. So they're asking for the
following relief.
So uh TEI, so that's Ethan Klein wants to be awarded defendants.
So that's both the mods and denims and uh and just listen to
this. They want to have all the profits plus the losses. So,
not only the money that this is like actual damages, wouldn't
you? Wouldn't that I feel like the profits and losses would have
to be somewhat balanced. Denim made, but also more importantly,
the money that Ethan lost because Ethan lost more money than
than Denim's made because Ethan gets paid. How do they determine
how this gets split too would be my question. Isn't it the same
money? Not necessarily. Um, like let's say somebody took away
a bunch of my viewers on kick and like rereamed to them on Rumble.
Technically, they wouldn't be making that much money, but like
viewers getting taken away from me on kick with KCIP would earn
me a lot of money, right? So, those aren't the same thing necessarily.
More for his views than Denims does because he has sponsors and
other things like that that go into the equation. So, she's getting
DPD, double punished, right, by her profits. That's going to
go to Ethan and plus losses.
Exact statutory damages in the amount of
of the chat. She is going to have to pay the losses
of Ethan Klein plus her revenue
plus at least at minimum at minimum 150k. you got. So, here's
another example of him being like a total rep probate who doesn't
understand the law or read anything before he comments. Uh 150k
is not the minimum damages, not the minimum statutory damages.
It's the maximum. And he just stated that totally incorrectly.
I I
want to be I wanted to be friends with this guy because he has
a flare for content, but I think he is like it's a
It's crazy how far off the mark he can be with some of his legal
opinions. 50k on the top. That is spicy. Or or hold on. I'm pointing
out. So the example of when I knew this guy was when he way overblue
what Destiny would be liable for in his case and I had to be
like, whoa, he's like not reading the actual law here at all
or not understanding it or both. Yeah, that's that's like and
that that was like right after it happened that I was like, oh,
this guy's like actually a [__]
And the judge could elect, by the way, the judge could elect
to not employ statuto damages and can use the other method, right?
But I'm saying if they choose statuto damage, 150k plus the damage.
That's a lot. That's a That's cooking. Also, attorneys fees
also. Wait, can you only wait hold on holding the exact sum to
be proven at the time of trial or if elected statutory damages?
Wait, so the judge can actually decide themselves whether or
not they want to apply statutory damages? Oh, that would be very
funny here if that gets uh ruled against Ethan. I don't think
it would because I've seen I've seen way more egregious versions
of these statutory damages being awarded. Like again, the one
I go back to is I think over Napster some dude shared a song
on to like six people and got 6xed on uh statutory damages. I
don't think they were that high. I think they're like 10,000
or 15,000 each instead of 150. But yeah, the 10 or 15 each, yeah,
seemed kind of brutal. Fences zero success rate. Uh Chedashad
uh Hari 7735 says Denims is super copyright again in the future.
Can her malicious intent uh here be used against her? Uh can
it be used in any specific conditions? Um
malicious intent is definitely something that's relevant and
it might be able to be used in different aspects. Been apparently
over 25 years. Say I Hold on. I would love to hear him explain
how malicious intent is uh is going to be relevant. Malicious.
Malice. analysis
cuz I would just love to see it like explained somewhere. All
right, I think I'm going to roll out. I got to go to bed. I got
to move tomorrow. Moving to Phoenix. Out of Oh, you're moving
out of Danny's and over to Phoenix. That's crazy. All right,
good luck. All right. Uh, we can talk about this more later.
Yeah, maybe a couple days or something. You're back. Okie dokie.
Have a good one. See you guys later. See you later. Byebye. Oh
my god. I don't think I'm going to finish the Pisco Hutch, guys.
Hold on. How far do we have to go here? How far do we have to
go? But second of all, he No, we we have to because I mean the
pine comes in after
I think you're
um I can't do it. It's like 20 minutes. I I can't like 20 more
minutes. Okay. No, I can't do like 20 more minutes, guys. I'm
sorry. I'll save the time stamp and maybe we can finish it when
I get up. But yeah, we just went seven hours. Okay. So, thank
you guys all for being here. I appreciate it. Uh should be back
tomorrow. Yeah, should be back tomorrow. Have a good night.
Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. Good night. We'll
talk to you guys later. Okay.